let's try that over again okay there we are
doing more on this Vapor local communities
set up and
I've been trying to get the cube ATM set up
in I setup a cluster has a vagrant which
comedian which is the proper way to setup a
cluster on friend if you don't have cloud
and so it's got dive in so just to review
I drove you here we start out with you need
to have a Linux workstation setup you need a
deliver to keep me install this cup took a
couple days there's another live on that we
need to install Baker naked pictures of her
which which is also couple days yesterday we
accomplish the task of the city of trees
real machines in them and vagrant and catch
up so
have a vagrant file here which we found out
the hard way that you had to provision
memory and see if you can buy a provider
which is weird because what if you want
different memory and see if you pronounce we
still in I don't know how to do that
somebody knows please let me know and then
we're we're looking through three different
note nodes in her name and you could do this
was like the numbers if you wanted to if you
think you're at the the names but I do I
want to have a different name so even though
they're the same the same you know base
image we're going to have control node want
to do to control be the match control plane
for three days and no one wanted to be the
worker knows it's a little just put the name
in there and we're using the Elma operating
system which is Center West without
association with red hat is reported to have
fewer bugs and security flaws according to
Cham chamke and others in the Stream so
we're going without me and said even though
it's got point-for-point compatibility so
you can eat I'm hearing about riding
Lenox you can use them instead Fun Pack
Alma's a referral reference to a Spanish
word for emotion not the Mormon Book of
Mormon prophet in case you're wondering so
no provider the need to make sure to have
this in here and I'm so surprised it's
working out discs allocation hear
provisioning we talked a shell script which
is just easier than trying to bed she'll
hear it most it for no other reason than to
send text to Anthony because I can actually
do it here and there was some additions to
this from the last of odd that I wanted to
cover really quick that I did off stream so
all the rest of this is fine we did our yum
updates we grab the doctor c e which is the
way I might change his container to you but
I did dr. sebi use this container tea so I
think we're going to be good I just read
that 1.24 will be there will be no backward
support hey
there will be no backward support for for
the doctor see him but I understand it
darker seat is ready for that when that
happens I did not talk about is using this
method we did get agency vagrant
Essex edge control Cube seashell version we
get ready 1.23 so that still has a SIM
support in it but we're going to be leaving
we're still following the regular this is
new mean evil doctor see you on there this
is new. The installation instructions to
still says to turn swap off even though
there's a there's a public blog it says you
no longer need to turn swap off it's not a
problem but I would rather not test that I'm
just going to go and do what they say it is
still officially on the documentation page
return swap off this turn Spotify off on
under this provision strip Highway runs
after each of the virtual machines has
created it runs this stuff on there and all
those by the way our asynchronous each node
gets brought online one at a time it's it's
kind of slow but whatever we can probably
fix that is a big one thing but I want to
look at it right now
enable Bridge traffic this this is something
that was not in the previous provision
script I added this based on the
instructions from the communities that I
have documentation which were going to
return you in a bit I'm not acquainted with
how bridgenet filtering Works in then and
the networking of the colonel I don't have
that level of knowledge and I do want to
come back and circle back
back in circle back and understand little
bit better but it's always something you
have to look up every time that I had
forgotten about it and was really kind of
encourage to find this means go ahead and
Cat all the stuff
but you have to do the Sioux call on the
actual command is going to do the writing so
this is how you do it and that that that's
neat I really like that that is a this is a
bug by the way wow I'm so glad I looked at
that I just found a bug
I found a bug that's why my own network
Bridges went working oh shit no kidding well
I'm glad it went through it so this says put
those lines into this file and said yeah t
is my default I think rights to the file I
don't know if she a pain that he gives you
that shaver
she is a it just branches it is a panic
attack so he's going to overwrite the file
which is fine cuz we don't need it it's not
there I checked before I did this you know
and check and see if I was there to tell
this restarts the system like networking and
everything is another really great thing
from the insulation docks that I'm really
appreciated that the people who were at the
installation. Really know their system
ministration and I'm really grateful for
them for having written up so well it was
them that that taught me about enable dash
dash now I have some people coming other day
that never seen that before and enable
actually been able to service and starts at
the same time if you push that just know I
said you wasn't able to start so that's
information that's that's in the docks swap
off thing as well just technique is is
something new to me the whole piping to see
that something also need to me
historically speaking
I don't know I think you could probably in
Bosch you can probably do this a different
way without the cat but that's plenty good
for me and then this this is a a reset of
the system with a network to spare key and
stuff I like this is something I was not
aware of this appears to reset all of
systems including the network stack so that
you do make iptable change network related
changes you can restart I don't know if
that's true but I believe that's it and that
give you some pictures also shows you how to
disable to see when it's which is an issue
now for us because when it comes on it
appears that has the Olympics comes on a
red-headed flashlights by The Faults I've
now heard that from three from people so W12
doesn't come with us he likes my default
which is probably why is preferred for
containers of any substantial size that they
need to sort of a eunuch see environment
just that alone would be reason for me not
to run right out in a container but but as a
whole system that complies with laws is up
and I was in the shower today actually I was
thinking about this feeling he says I know
I'm on weird I think about the ceiling next
to the shower and I just want to say that
this particular thing and cause me to do I
mean this is turning it off tonight and
tired because we're using a local cluster
this running within vm's then it protected
Network Newbridge environment but but using
selinux having a c Lennox on Enterprise
Linux isn't really strong argument for using
this in fact I need to edit a file as at it
but I did recently
see you then dandified yums the new yum
and it's anything is Young's going away by
the way and it seems to be coming at dbny I
think Danny fight him
I'm trying to find it that I did so by there
it is
I want to add to this thought I was having
other day about why red hat is got the
control point if you're making Enterprise
decisions right has really the pic I don't
particularly like that that's true or just
his true so
it's also that red hat
rhel comes with SE Lenox making it compliant
with many government
andthe security industry standards
I don't believe
Ubuntu Server does is that another thing you
have to install there's a lot of companies
and governments that have that is a standard
so definitely something to consider there
so we turned it off and then what then we
have this so this is the official way from
the documentation site to Stew and salsa
from Cuba to the list other unlike by the
way are in the read me and in every Pokemon
go get it so the repo is this this is this
is my lap for this if you want to follow
along all the way to stuff has been
committed so that's what I came from so this
says hey let's try to tell Mo stanza which
is what this is it's actually nice and I but
it's it looks and I am the same thing I made
the tunnel over by the way and so are
kubernetes
I don't know what this is but I have a
feeling that this is gets replaced this is
something there some subjects about you and
we have to learn about unless it turns on
yes enable kubernetes turn on GPS to check
so this is how he is essentially you know i
p p a i had you know but for Young Jeezy but
you can't we just because I haven't seen
this I haven't seen how to do this and young
for last 10 years and just be you could just
use that in a file and did it and then I
guess it's still the same thing for the most
part they did do it I am not repost. D
situation which is nice. He's got that
problem with everything sharing the same key
ring and they're trying to get off of that
but all right she alright I almost sent a
message that they don't have it yet another
you know a little indicator that that
redhead is better for business for
enterprise-scale applications for hosting
and stuff so again I have no love for red
head but it but that's just the State of
Affairs
he is a Jeep Cherokee if it's in there and
then I don't know why this is a thing
I think the reason that they put excluding
here is because we know that we never ever
want to auto-update these three we want
explicitly update them this was not in there
is another installation guide I found it was
almost identical except for his missing the
exclude line and I want to take note of that
because the exclude line is super important
they exclude line says do not update these
packages if someone doesn't act update or
whatever a yum update write the update or
upgrade it says leave them out don't touch
these unless I tell you to and and then
that's important because and you have to
actually explicitly when you get on your
insulin if they explicitly say no I do not
want to I want to I actually do want to not
exclude these things and I want to force an
upgrade and I really like
that's another really subtle but really
crazy good infrastructure engineering thing
is because it's so totally important that
your Cuba Cuba ATM and keep CDL stay the
same aversion is your infrastructure if
somebody accidentally gets on the system and
run update or some like that and then it
would blow up that machine is a note which
may even still be running jobs and that's
bad and I we don't want that so you want to
turn those things out this is very very slow
but a very cool thing and I'm actually I'm
actually kind of getting into the decision
to go with Alma even more that Ben is coming
on these tiny little bit super details and
super informed decisions about how to manage
a server and those are those people really
matter in the Enterprise so anyway 7420 I've
seen a couple people attempt to do this in
different ways this is apparently turn the
ceiling lights off
said that she has the same as propane by the
way it just unfortunately is forced to use
basic regular Expressions to save the power
of pro regular Expressions you could do the
same thing with pearl Pio it would literally
be the same thing you could do Pearl. P h i
a c and it would be exactly the same thing
except for you be able to use proper I guess
I've seen a lot of said I out in the world
in
dial in the world in people know that says
going to be on there and it's pretty
standard so whatever I am annoyed that you
have to learn three different regular
expression formats to be a true Unix person
you have to learn basic regular Expressions
extended regular expressions and pearl
regular Expressions if you want to be
serious so yum install that and I still make
some of the time I can ever remember I have
a fat guy we need to do a whole thing I just
go through the difference between I do have
a ride here I guess book somewhere right so
I just find it annoying that they're so
different so here's the actual install of
the components and then we have this is Alan
able which turns the Cubit on people might
be wondering if they've gone through Kelsey
Hightower is the hard way thing I like
healthy height H the hard way tutorial is
really really out of date it's really a
the entire premise of the tutorial if you've
heard about it is that you would in the old
book pre atx2 ATM is free to ATM days that
you would go in and you would build your
cluster with each component you'd give
provisional certificates you download the go
buy an Aries you wouldn't even run a Daemon
set Azure as your cube in a proxy and all
that stuff it's so totally ancient I cannot
overstate my recommendation that you just
skip it and find something that teaches you
Cube ATM night namely the official
documentation because Cube ATM very
specifically was created to make it
consistent and easy for everybody to use it
by putting everything in a phased approach
so that's the way you should be doing this
you should be using to radium if you're not
using Cube ATM you're at risk of breaking
things in ways that you may not even
understand and it is hands-down that it's an
important understanding individual
absolutely and thank you for that it's
really really important that you understand
any of the components and with the phases
due and again I suggest strongly that you
read go learn how to read go so you can read
the code of comedian the code of cute a
medium literally contains the codified steps
that are original that originated from
something like Kelsey Hightower doing it the
hard way book or tutorial their codified in
there it's shows you exactly what it does if
you need to go you say hey imma do this step
and I may just stop, just stop and you can
keep it and do it all for you if you want to
understand all the stuff that's necessary to
set up communities you can go one step
further and actually read the code and I'll
read the sources so that's it you need to
see if it's not you, thank you cuddle so I
said today was like really okay keep CTL
control
I can sense her
it's a I think a skill has to work a command
something it's command terminal thing yeah
but it doesn't stand for control
what is Cube cgl give odds
beginners number as a convention is like
becoming popular all over the place now you
hear you see cluster CDL and a CDL actually
stands for something I think it's command
line interface but I can't run with the t is
I don't remember so I want to know what it
stands for
que si que no
I used to know and I don't know who you are
I don't know what he has so many ways have
to install it to I'm going to go into the
hole that's on the bigger thing right
gives you 2 over you
to to to to do hey how are you Swiffer
Duster B dustbuster
I can't remember what it stands for someone
who knows better until he is it conventional
language I think it's I think you might be
but I don't remember
I cannot send it it says like really
he's like really scared. I knew it was about
time it's commands something though and it's
it's not control what is que tal
maybe maybe I don't know you know what let's
go look at the source code the sick of this
source code
a container image 08 that was dumb do do do
do I know I have to find the ethanol this
right now
I'm sorry I just do
what does it say in the read me
so I just realizing things that blah blah
blah where you at I got to write that stuff
down
maybe it isn't my thing
negative or I can just cry I asked my rock
thing
it's not I don't think it's I don't think
it's control I used to think that I used to
think it was CTL stand for control
and then I read it didn't and he read it did
it
oh
what information reference or a we did that
we still in there
I mean it's not that important but I kind of
can't leave this alone now
I know it's something else
what does Ctrl + Cube SEAL stand for
what does qtl stand for simply what does
keeps yelling command line tool
rich like a man cars a thing
Cecil stands for control I don't think it
does
I don't think it does I don't think it does
all right well I could have been wrong the
reservations you can you control Q cuddle q
c t l
rqq cuddle cuddle cuddle cuddle how does
cuddle and cuddle defrag necessity is Lowes.
I guess it's control I have been generous I
have been corrected
Chris is not acceptable I guess it's control
does the second thing that says it says for
control Kim ctrlq got on
turn light to
give energy when i m MSP control
I was calling you control and and I heard
somebody said no don't call Kim control
anymore I would know
I say CDL I am not going to say come cuddle
as he touches his plushie touch my plushie
and I find I guess I was wrong yes it is I
guess it is definitely control
assembly control I feel I feel schooled
I feel School than this I could have swore I
saw somebody maybe that one person got it
wrong maybe that was it I definitely read
something that said it was command something
something
is esoteric little bits of side rib pain
that takes up 20 minutes
I can't stop now get my I'm done I'm done
call it whatever you want I'm give a shit
all right so what are we going to do this is
the documentation yeah we don't want that
either all right so let's try this.
I hate academic heads why are you are you
coming here where you can always
you can always rent in here if you need to
rent a unit B against me and to agree to a
degree in the mouth and then come back and
we make up and then we will go our separate
ways
all right let's run this shall we you think
it is
it is control apparently there's another one
for you is it Nick card or is it just Nick
420 trivia points is it Nick card is it Nick
or Nick card
yes I do know what I'm talking about these
things, the harder it is so it's not even a
thing it be used to be you had a thing you
put it on whatever you put in there
I was actually giving I gave a field trip to
a bunch of Mentor kids and I had I had a
network engineer
yeah just going to be a fun one is going to
be a fun one so
at the hall I can afford all the Heather
Grace
no I didn't read it read it go watch her go
I'm going to help you out here you'll laugh
okay
I'ma I'ma give you a video you going to
watch me laugh your ass off and then
it's like it's like their body their head is
detached from their body the body is kind of
a transport for their head have you ever
seen that I've ever seen you really have to
see this video especially right now if
you're having a hard time with it go back
and you'll see this thing why is prime
showing up on my stuff I don't give a shit
about prime stuff
not interested don't recommend Channel thank
you very much let's go to Ken Robinson
did you laugh your ass off of this and I
make you laugh so much
yeah I can't find it it's like but if you
watch it
there's there's a quote in there or like
academics just like their body is a vehicle
for their head
he says that the whole education system is
broken can because it's built on making
everybody into academics because that's
where the priority is and that's why it's
broken
yeah Nick Cave
nobody's got the right answer so far so far
no one's got the right answer
no one's got the right answer I had to look
it up I had to look it up
is it Nick or is it Nick hard
I'll give you a hint what could the sea
possibly stand for besides card
we're happy to report that I was right
and it's this frantic asshole engineer my
favorite kind
the carnival he gave me
gave me so much shit over there I was like I
was showing the kids you know he gave us he
gave us all these like 5 or Channel
connector so you probably seen him right he
gave it as souvenirs to our field trip and I
took I had all my kids are with me showing
off you know Davidson College and he said he
said yeah it's a pet peeve of mine I said I
said yeah so it's like it's like so what is
this so that plugs into the NIC card and
goes and yeah yeah except for it's not in
the car that's one of the things that I know
I like the same it oh and I felt School than
shot down exact them all you got at Schweddy
Balls sweaty balls got it
so any of any pedantic engineer or network
person who ever tells you that Nick card is
incorrect is themselves incorrect because
it's not redundant the sea is not redundant
the C stands for controller you dumbass
that's the proper response and I didn't say
that I said but I know that saying you can
say Nick is fine and in that Nick because
sometimes it's a Nick it doesn't have a card
right so it's actually important because
sometimes you just see where some computers
come with a nick
on the board and some need a Nick card
ohmygod I actually use the word and its
proper context is there now you know
I only know that because I felt school after
that I went back I felt really you know bad
that I didn't know it at all my goddamn is
saying it wrong all this time and if I do
I'll look it up and I'll stay here and tell
him I said hey you know what you were wrong
God knows have been plenty wrong many many
times so this is about being right or wrong
it's about having right before so I think I
use the Nick interface is a network
interface controller interface
ucenik interface card face controller
interface card
don't do that don't be mean I just I just
thought it was fun so fun fact fun fact
I mean God knows we're helping out of here I
want to show you actually know we're going
to start from a fresh slate we are we're
going to and I killed all my DMs because I
was playing DOTA and not do The Witcher and
it was killing my winter and I had to admit
to it take this Troy I'm going to destroy
I'm a destroy this provision using Baker
would like to destroy no to yes please would
I like to just Roll No 21 yes please yes
please make sure you put a vagrant and
you're getting or if you going to do this so
they should let you know
all those machines and everything they get
stored in. Vagrant which I have not exploded
into
I don't feel the need to write this moment
but vagrant vagrant
the vagrants very bigger than it too so now
it may Grant going to be up this thing now
does he do everything and if you take a
while so grab your coffee and music
and will do this as my fan comes on and
you know I write off 6 GB of RAM and
6 virtual CPUs
just for this if you're going to do this
make sure you take it down
later cuz you might not have the horsepower
to do it El Metate
extra packages for Enterprise Linux
look at all that stuff it's got python on
their eyes got darker
oh that's the key stuff
I don't know if I have a DVD on there
actually
baby missing a step for the GPS. Hey do you
know if I have to do the Pod and saw her
step anyways probably go show that was will
keep watching this but
there's a step in insulation Doc's now that
says that you should grab the Pod plug-ins
for the for what I think it's
it's not the end of the sea and I but I
think you made him comes along by default
because of that see what they did in
kubernetes is in order to keep everything
you know flexible they ripped Docker out for
example they rip the storage class out and
they rip the specific networking out and
they created
they created the container was a c c
are I create the creative container runtime
interface
I put your aunt right still a fake did you
find us yeah so
if there's like the container runtime
interface
which is that came from Germany's actually
saying hey if you wanted Implement
containers just implemented this
and then the container
network interface to cni which implements
the networking layer for pods and everything
which is creole plus pod man and then the
CSI not like a CSM is at Miami it's like the
container storage in her face so and if that
ass or hard disk whatever that wants to talk
has to inform me that those three
abstractions are what gets implemented hey
how's it going by those are things that get
implemented by vendors and projects that
want to be a part of the community ecosystem
so if you're wondering why I'm being so
verbose about this is because I'm solidified
my own learning by talking about it you know
and it helps hey look okay so it looks like
a provision everything
so we can go ahead and do vagrants is it
Lister status I think it's status
as if it's where I always would confuse it
with Roy sh so there we have
I felt if I cannot hard
yeah yeah I actually think of that for
themselves yeah
yeah we tried for you at work and it crashed
and burned so I don't know why I
specifically is why I'm doing this locally
on my own we had we had to stop team is
sitting up in Alaska search cluster and on
that cluster it it really blew up actually a
pretty bad and so had to go back to actually
they were just using container to you
without doctor's he and it blew up and point
to OneBlood pretty badly I don't know the
details of it I did wasn't involved but I
would really love to be able to use a 30 or
one of the other container runtime engines
but
make dinner is amazing. Can you answer the
question if you're on doctor see you have
container T already you don't need to worry
about 1.24 right
because it'll do it at the only thing that
might run be differently as the detection
Soca medium has a set of rules for detecting
weather what run time engine is on there
yeah I don't think anybody needs to panic I
saw that this today I saw the post about
that today yeah there was it when it was on
new stack it came across so just set up
three virtual machines and installed all
that software in under you know 3 minutes so
kind of cool right you think it's really
great about this is I can rip the whole
thing down and do it all again when I've
saved you from the elastic do you think so I
think that was the problem yeah I don't know
what it was but but there was something
related to that so why am I doing this why
would you maybe want to do what I'm doing
with a girl if you want to be able to
quickly
practice provisioning an entire kubernetes
cluster from scratch with repetition helps
you learn it right then this is the way to
do it this is the way to do a handstand and
it seems to me that would be the easiest if
you want to do things like metal lb and set
up your own in a load balancing and stuff
locally On and On from cluster that that are
all set up for you if you's a cloud if you
want to practice on friend kubernetes setup
call Natives you know set up yet this is the
only way to go buy that short of going to do
your own Hardware which is going to be the
next the next phase of this actually so so
let's do it if I actually have another spot
four
but let's do this so I'm going to log into
the control
into the control plane it did tell me my
ain't my things but I I don't need to
remember them it takes care of maker and
takes care of all the the DNS and everything
so I don't have to deal with it
SSH that will lock me in and no zip and
everything and it will always remain the
same you can't give them hoes names but I
found that I didn't really need you there
at some point it might mean if I wanted to
do something with a client but if I was
going to that I probably would do it on its
own VM as well I don't do anything on the
host of us at all so so now we're on here
and we can see we got all our stuff here
right cubes ETL version is here Cube ATM
version is here we have cubelets
version it's not here couplet is not a thing
Q let version a boy barely Q what is dash
dash version
Al Bundy's resume so we have
if they got me out of that keeps ETL
we had a cube let and we have comedian so
there's an emergency run 1.23 which is the
default by the way that was their fault that
was installed by if you want you can add a
switch to your installer to get Knightley's
if you want to do that let me just show you
I don't want to do that but I might in the
future because maybe I want to try out the
new stuff right I want to try out the new
karate stuff that would mean adding where is
it
there you go you would change the modules
that you load down here
yeah they have another one for nightly that
you can get
but this is a standard want to get in this
came straight off the Q communities
documentation site which is one of the only
sites that in the GitHub is the only those
are the only things you can access during a
certification so it's good to get from there
without that's what you want to do and now
we're connected so it's time to run to ATM
let's go back and find our guide so I didn't
write this pretty much just a matter this is
this is how it works I understand it you
either one either start the keyboard first
and then run qbdm and it will find it or you
start Cube ATM first and then you work you
blood and it will the phone home but you
have to do that you can do it on that for so
we can do nothing control plane itself and
I'm going to get that so I want to go back
and read the docks on that though so
kubernetes
IQ ATM set up I have a link to this but I'm
just going to go get it this way so I had to
go through the Canadian installation
I can't use that resource so I'm going to
use this one you can only use the community
site so this is the official site
is that normal stuff on him a texturizer I
care I follow all these things too far
because again I'm doing this for you create
an enviable classic minis cost at confirms
the best practices in fact you think you
need a list of the closest will pass
security cameras performance test I always
when I first read this I found it odd that
that they were making a big deal of that
because that implied that there was some
other way and you know that's that's me
understand the hard way from Kelsey
Hightower because that that was the other
way was doing all the individuals implicated
in by yourself why the fuck would you want
to do that I just makes me crazy thank you
but I think they should change the language
in personally I think they should they
should yeah I think that they should I ain't
being you know compliant I think it's really
important and it is upsetting recommended
before if you want to understand the
intricacies of cute. He is in the hard way
do learn go and go read The Source BBQ baby
damn which is that definitive source for how
to setup a cluster so cute medium is also
supports other customer lifecycle functions
which are tokens and custom upgrades as good
if you need see it's like oh hey maybe
oh hey maybe you don't need to keep ATM to
him I'm like when would you not need it
you are a mini Cuban kind for a localized
development or 2 a.m. that's it I don't see
how anybody can think that there are other
options out there apparently there are and I
feel like this this this documentation is
written with the idea of it too broadly that
suggests hey you know you don't have to use
keep it in and you can do it the really
fucking hard way
but the language kind of tends to suggest
that a this is just one best way to do it
but you don't have to do this way I wish you
would be more opinionated about that
personally but but this is not opinionated
it's opinionated about apis and stuff it's
not opinionated about you no specific
invitation sand that tends to be I think a
problem for beginners I just tell me what to
do right now and I'm going to say that what
you do is give idiom
it's a way for you to track your base
possibly for the first time you know it's a
simple way to track communities for the
first time many Cuban kind
so I don't keep it in already we're about to
wait for existing I want to lead up to it I
want you to see where we go where we go from
there and test application which is what I
want to do many Cuban kind of are both ways
for that as well the difference is that the
way we're going to be doing it now hey look
we are bidding me for things that are not
failures thank you and I miss you and other
ecosystem installer tools at larger scope so
these things are all true but if you've been
around the block a little bit and we could
raise land you like yeah but I can automate
to automate setting up a cluster Aunt Esther
application okay but yeah I can do that with
mini cube right just an application the only
time you would ever want to do cute in my
opinion the only time you would ever want to
use comedian for testing application is when
you want to do what I'm trying to do right
now which is you want to write applications
that tests the limits of the nodes in the
systems are running on or you want to
integrate anifest using a driver storage
class that can only be properly tested in a
true machine environment and not buy
emulated containers or even in a VM in a
modified BMC mini cube is so so yeah are the
easiest right it's so I mean yeah there's
this assumption in the community
architecture documentation as well that most
people will be coming using it in a cloud
and they will have to deal with any of this
and so I just no reason to mention it at all
is because
it is kind of hard to navigate the tone of
the documentation sometimes because it seems
to imply like you're missing something like
there's some other thing out there and it
doesn't tell you what the other thing is and
it leaves you with this feeling like I don't
know you know I don't know what I'm missing
and that's not good when you're trying to
learn so what I'm saying is I believe after
your research on this that qbdm is the way
to understand kubernetes hands down if you
want to understand the intricacies of
communities at every level and still
incubate a m into a local cluster of nose
made of machines virtual or otherwise is the
only true way to understand the internals
and every aspect of communities in my
opinion every other way as some sort of you
know magic that keeps you from truly
understanding it and so that's that's why
I'm on this move on now
I'm going to sell these kid video on various
machines your laptop instead of cloud
servers Raspberry Pi and more than this this
I strongly recommend you do this whether
you're deployed into the cloud or on-premise
didn't say bigger in here I mean that you
know anyway whether to fly into a cloud
around friend you can integrate you biniam
is a vision systems is national telephone
yeah that I did not understand is I didn't I
didn't understand the order so really this
is how it goes you get a machine if we give
me I'm in the Shoe City on there and your
incubating minute the end and then you add
another note and then you bring that one on
me to bring me to do slowly out of so that's
the price that I want to write that as a
diagram because I feel like I feel like
that's that's that needs to be visualized
more for for me anyway and for others before
you begin to guide you need this and I
actually set this up exactly the way I
needed
exactly the way I needed without even
reading this you need a estimated it right
you need one of the machines running Linux
you need two gigs or a machine to see if
he's on the machine for the control plane I
went ahead and get to see if you so I know
it's probably stupid but but you don't get
in this is just temporary I can change it by
also if I had made try to make one see if
you for that and Tuesday because it would
have made my Vigor and file a bit more
complicated because you can only change the
fuse and memory as far as I know today by
provider and not buy VM which is weird but
whatever iPhone network connectivity among,
she's in the closer okay so this is the
tricky part for me you have to set up your
IP Bridges and stuff like that and they talk
to you about it then you'll see University
of making it for the Russian commanders you
want
if you can't even keep it get out of sync by
more than two versions a stops working so
that's why the installation rules put that
exception in there because if you
accidentally update your cubits and it gets
past the version that supported by your bank
already server at they will stop working as
built into the code so communities version
of version skus for policy here you go. This
is this is exactly what I can I play
stickman team is supposed to be nice or I'll
check the policy to learn about what person
created to give me a supported for Cuban
Eddie's 1.23 Teresa larocque future General
the Villi are still active element and I
don't I guess they didn't say it there they
say to another place though
so objectives to sell a single propane
cluster gauge cluster assault pod Network on
the closest to your place and talk to each
other and that's my exact subjective keep
going it's all on your hosts I already have
given him his salt I did after update
install this interesting so when you when
you start your queue but it says
now it sucks going to start your cumulative
effect let me do this so I forgot about this
I want to show this so cute we'll get
started cuz it has service right here what
is a service of the machine it's not a
Daemon set or some shit keep Roxie is a dama
said inside of cubed that's different than
the front scratch tutorial by the way it
uses a separate binary so if you keep CTL
gives his suit assistance ETL and we say
status cubelet that you will see it's it's
like broken
what I said ice not cuddle at god dammit
it's not there so it's loaded it's
activating and it's like fail fail fail fail
because trying to phone home and there's no
there's no home to phone too because that's
what your baby in and it does when you get
there so that it says you're so cute it's
automatically going to start talking in that
that clarify something I said earlier you
want to do this stuff first and then this is
way before you went to bed again if you
don't have an activated Cuba on your main
points you probably want to start work keep
working on it
okay it will crash leave and tell it to do
the crash that was expected or control plane
that can
after you initialize your control plane
which we have not yet done and it should be
called to give me a medium and it control
plane because that's what it does it doesn't
just end it anything it turns a system into
a control plane explained well anywhere so
far after two years of looking I did not get
an easy handling this so I'm going to I'm
going to I'm going to get this out really
quick at all this is in preparation of the
way for the my calendar event to Caboose to
do the careers application Busan Korea
administrator boost I am not a aventurine am
not the best person to give these things but
I we have people here 21 others who are very
down-to-earth as a beginner just like any
beginner I think we're in a unique position
to simplify an explanation to other beginner
so let me go with us
are you a March later I I don't I don't want
to my going to get my test
I know I think it's every its its next one
is he gay is going to be the next the next
boost that we do not really going to be a
boost this time this those to calendar
calendar items
take your time off thank you and I'm kind of
working so so if you're a beginner the
things you think about here is
you have a bunch of machines right one of
our machines were so otherwise that's where
he start preferably sent to us a redhead of
some kind that's restart got a bunch of
machines and you want to turn it into a
Career Cluster that's the first thing the
second step is to put all of the Baseline
components that turn those machines into
kubernetes nodes
the thing that it's not explain well
anywhere is that every single one of those
machines has to be a node
was confusing to me is the idea that I was
going to have a note in the control point
when I heard the term control plane. Plane
at that what is that mean that it's a plane
is that within a single computer or is it
across multiple computers that uses it can
be any of those things but most of the time
when you start a control plane is a
kubernetes node that's been turned into a
control plane her control not a controller
as a control because it has all the the main
stuff the controller's run it so it's all
these all these nodes are these machines and
the other nodes state workers
they don't have any of the extra cool magic
on them all they have is the three primary
can put for crap primary components write
the four primary components of they say
three but I think there's four right so that
that that the three components that turn a
machine into an ode are cubits cute cute
cute cute proxy add a container runtime
engine membrane you go look at that a
component of most weight but in terms of
installing packages this thing we drove me
crazy you install you can and probably
should install keep medium keep CDL and 2
but on every single note you're probably not
going to be running qbdm on your end points
on your notes right you're the only going to
probably run that on the control plane
machines no it's not even calling this is so
so yeah machines and then you turn all the
machines into nodes and then you turn one or
one or two or three of those notes into
control plane notes and they're redundant
and they talk to each other and stuff like
that that's the that's the process you start
with machines and then you turn all the
machines into nodes and then you turn one or
more of those nose into control plane notes
and the rest of the notes stay the same and
they are now worker notes that's the process
of elevating the installation and so what
we're about to do now
is we already got all our nose right there
about to take one of those notes an elevated
into a control plane mode and just on one of
them though and it might be that control
play node Still Remains a note it still has
Cube CDL and and and cuboid everything
running on it has to write a contract with
Nomad Nomad has a single binary that gets
installed everywhere as an agent that
snowman is hatch courts alternative
communities and its importance and set up
for that reason it's one of its biggest
bonuses if you don't need all the
orchestration stuff from communities so here
we have given him
okay preparing require container images we
did this already
all right so this step preparing to require
container images this step is optional in
place in case you wish she's keeping him in
it and she didn't join to not download end
of the default container images which are
hosted so this is interesting this is
exactly what I am doing okay it is possible
I don't think that's going to get you
anything in terms of like knowledge to just
download the standard images and say okay I
want an air control plane okay I want to
think it's probably worth looking at the
images though instead but where do it the
hard way and which isn't the hard hard way
like Kelsey talks about this is like the
medium standard hard way we're going to eat
Cube ATM for this so what is que Dia in it
on on the control plane on the nose who
wanted to turn in control by the way to
curium join on the workers and then that
most of them into kind of changing their
genetics and turning them into into workers
in and controllers control planes
give me a give me a
give me a man has commands to help you that
and I can help you improve pull it apart a
microwave cost without an internet
connection intermittent without internet
connection for more details if you have or
get out of sorts of things I don't but that
is worth doing I probably will do that at
some point because knowing how to set up an
air gap, days environment is is a mandatory
requirement for give you a contractor if you
got me sitting up on Prime committee's
clusters for companies you definitely need
to know how to do it without having a solid
internet connection all the time so I'm glad
I reread that because I need to go back and
get your presents were for the required
images of CEUs custom images with details
yet again another reason and air gap thing
we use we're getting a harbor is our new
image registry I believe that's the best in
the in an industry that's another piece of
your infrastructure by the way that is not a
part of kubernetes it's outside of
kubernetes
or at least it should be a can be we will be
actually setting up a registry that now runs
in kubernetes is kind of chicken the eggs
situation going on but we're going to do
that Harbor runs in kubernetes engine size
in control all right so this is what we're
doing this is exactly where we are right now
it could help him load is going to wear at
CVS the brain the database communities and
the API servers a listen to 6445 I think
which the committee control blank meets with
if you had plans to upgrade a single 12
playing comedian close to the high
visibility should specify the control point
to the Sheraton Point Rock and Roll by nodes
such as such an important can be either
genus name and IP address to the bouncer so
this is if you want to have more than one
system and I don't right now but I want to
Circle back and do this eventually write
send in in in in in in an Enterprise world
not setting up high availability that means
at least three machines more likes
so because of different about his three
machines that all answer their all their
they share it's it's a high-visibility set
up for two medium but I'm not doing that in
this case I'm just going to the single node
but knowing how to do that is definitely
important to do that and which case you have
to set up your own external load balancing
so stuffy nose what to connect to and you
can do that either with a DNS names that get
round robin in or some sort of you know all
about is if you don't know about external
load balancing and stuff you know you can
you can look at that so so yeah she's a
party at work at on and verify whether
requires any arguments we passed that you
made a minute so
this this wants us to pick a a c n i s a pod
a network interface and I do not have any
ideas about what personal cni that I would
prefer I'm not even sure you can do this
without a CNA but I'm pretty sure if you do
Cube ATM and it by itself it will use a
default see you and I but if you wanted to
override it you could again to see and I is
just the network component that goes on the
pot that that fulfills keep Roxie and all
the other networking stuff that happens and
I believe that's one of the reasons cute
proxy was made known jamun which is I'm
sorry I didn't say which which is a
community's thing that runs on every single
note as a container
and verify whether it requires then you're
going to be passing cube in it depending on
which their provider you choose again we are
not going to do a pot and workout on we're
just going to do queue in 6114 keeping them
tries to detect the container runtime on
Lenox by listing all the well-known to me so
I can pass to a different a new run time or
if there are more than one is solid
provisioning node specify their Korea sock
and argument to do any of you do not need to
do that we're using the dr. Cee which I
absolutely know works because it's so we use
so it should be picked up I'm a just going
to find the container T it doesn't go to
find a shame though because there's no sim
so it is should find it just fine on the
documentation I was reading documentation
about the detection of run times here
run times here and it said it look for a run
dr. shim but there is no bar on Dockers him
so I think what they meant was the other
Varma darker thing so I think I might be a
Miss I don't know if it's bad documentation
up you don't really care because it's the
cube it's going to find the right container
it if you're Cuban is running in Turkey what
is running than you know it found the red
container by the container on time and so
has a network interface associate with the
default gateway to send advertise the
address for the controller's which is fine
because we're all on our same Bridge number
address address argument I may have an issue
with being able to communicate with the API
from my whole machine using qcpl as opposed
to one of the nodes I'm at the port forward
but if I do I don't have to pour forward
and we have the bridge or whatever they 6445
main communities API in order to get qct
able to work from anywhere which is kind of
cool so this is just an API control playing
run node kubernetes Cube ATM and it ours
and you might want to put these other things
here is an example of a paying customer
hustler in point DNS when I can do that
without creating is not supported by giving
him a single control think lesser created
without an endpoint in 21 is not at work so
I guess they're over empathizing hey if
you're going to use aha later make sure you
take the time to do cute control plane and
point glad I read that
alright more information
and you're going to be an even it again you
must first hair down the cluster which I
ain't never done and not interested in doing
right now I Could Just Kill a bigger and
stuff and will be fine right it's the
restart if I do need to do it right so let's
do it so we are on the control
I am control we should be all right so let's
do it Cube ATM
and it and that's all you should have to do
over Studio course
70 minute pulling images necessary again if
you didn't have internet access I can do
that this is kind of fun to see this and it
to PreFlight stuff if you're looking for the
source code if you're looking to the source
could have few ATM this looking for these
different phases gives you very specific
details about what it's doing so when it
curls down the stuff and not curled it and
it tells you about all the search that
generates again all those are individual
steps in the Kelsey Hightower tutorial but
you made him doesn't for you why would you
want to fuck around certificates I just I
don't I don't know certificates at all I
mean I know that idea of them I do very
little maintenance of them it's probably
important eventually get that knowledge and
I it's on my list of things you can figure a
folder for netty's right now it's sitting
here waiting for a cubit to boot up the
control plane
this may take a while it might be fun to go
back and look at her and are actually SSH
only control that the first we have when
it's works we should have all her pots
should actually about phone home fine seems
like he isn't running or healthy I was
afraid of that so it seems like you but
isn't running or healthy the call they
should be called equal to blah blah blah was
refused so there's something going on with
networking it's it's unable to see
it is looking for local so that's kind of
weird why is it doing it connection refused
answer this is the this is a keyword
you know what though it's is looking for a
local hose which makes me
oh wait it would be called equal to curl
I'll see if it do I have to put you in on
the other one
yes this is a hard part so there is
Stephanie some network connectivity not
working between
connection it's the thing is though is its
trying to kubicek
yeah I keep my check is not happy it's going
to it's going to fill out yep there we go
so this happened last time and it had
something to do withhave something to do in
networking first Journal
Journal Ctrl f u f u cubed
filled with relaxing code
Felder and he would miss configuration he
would see group's history is different from
doctors secret drives to Europe FS
I would not have known that well there's one
thing it says cubed Seger driver
dr. cigarette driver
I wonder why
I see no networks found no I didn't install
the cni for the pods that's why
I thought I was going to get around that I
apparently not
I thought I was going to use the default I
skipped a step and is yelling at me I did I
skipped her
I skipped the step for the sea and iPods bad
container T socket
I think it's time I think it could be a
number of things I think it's that I think
it could also be
that you and Sophie and I are on top of a
running control by node yeah but it wasn't
I don't think the sea and I was installed at
all isn't there a default see and I I was
hoping I was hoping Beyond hope that there
would be a default C and I
so here we go we have
yeah it says here she's a pain that worked
out on and verify whether it requires any
arguments
you need everything is all plain all right
that's good to hear so it might be that it's
just not detecting it right when we saw that
you're right there so
Philadelphia Legal Texaco in process exit
we got the cell network not found
Uncle shopping plaza running the network at
with those that working really
I must have a load balancer I would think
right if they're on separate machines and
that way that's where you need the entry
point for h a
yeah okay so getting to darker
a secret Bear yeah what is a secret bear
because
because it detected the wrong container its
container engine
Under the Sea group is is a is a symptom of
it picking up the wrong container engine in
a run time so it feels when people that are
filtering people in this configuration
huguelet C group driver
systemd is different from Docker secret
driver
cigarfest
and the thing is trying to lose the doctor
right
foot doctor CA on here so
yeah
I think I might have to give you the exact
path to the to the thing they sell Docker
shim problem right
yeah we have to figure out where the socket
is actually
I thought it was Doctor run right doctor
sock
ain't this is that's what I'm used to doing
that's what I'm used to show me something
that's doctor only
I think it's looking for the shim and it's
not there which makes me wondering if I even
saw the red container engine I'm wondering
if I should take him home and install
container do you directly instead
you've got to have you go back and read the
docs on that so it does say
here we gothank you for your doctor use
systemd
Seagram I don't I don't know how to do that
oh wait either of them let's look at that
they sell in a container one time issues so
here's here's what I was talking about so
these are the things that are looked at to
detect right
and started to take darker that doesn't
exist and either this documentation is out
of date
or wrong what you can be both there is no
Docker shim
there is none and I think it's looking there
price of a container I think I'm going to
that right now yeah I'm reading it right now
so
I am reading the marina. Going right now it
was a great dinner to take the doctor takes
precedence
Lennar consumer information
I think
end times
let me go Docker engine. Hers is container
in science starts l490 soccer
eye doctor is right babe I will cure his
using those deprecated doctorsim component
my son's contacts to doctors and everything
he knows about thirty party thing
there is no doctor Chantelle it doesn't come
by default so
you know I'm trying to figure out how to
install that
but I think if I just changed my Kris Olga
to dog to the bar run run run dr. Stock I
think we'll be fine
I think it's I think it's an old and an old
issue
every time I felt the connectors yet
Jessie's getting ready
are you saying install container me instead
and then just be good with it and I don't
know how to talk to your niece let's go to
change my previous run time to get ready
instead of doctors him instead of doctor
what you going to do anything right I mean I
don't want it anyway so let's do that let's
do that
yeah I imagine that's actually covered over
here
I thought container T came with docker
sexual things that you said to use can you
use
I thought it was too and that's why
is picking the wrong thing I might just be
that I have to tell it what socket is it
where you know
I mean what I'm going to bring one thing I'm
going to try something relatively simple I
don't know if it's the right thing I just
want to see what works
how much my
did you give me the internet dash dash Cree
Cree engine right
and then God damn it I lost my thing
give me minutes
and this is there one
where is my page I was on I have it in my
distress
2 2 2 2 2 2
dr. info
she might isn't running right that's an
interesting one I haven't seen that before
Heavenly address I put that in her notes is
it running or what
I already did this I went through this whole
thing I'm going through it again now
yeah I read I just read that very with him
the problem is container is
not on there
yeah I just we just had it on the screen
actually the doctor takes presidents this is
needed because dr. ship security and both
are detectable even if you only still darker
if any other two are more run time to take
this makes me want to install container too
and just dropped fucking just fucking drop
doctor which I think is what everybody wants
to do right
yeah seems to get the community so I can if
I install Docker and I wanted you to get
energy socket there's another option here
though the other option is the backup for my
big reinstall and install can hear the only
instead of calling Consulting docker
yeah if I do that though then people won't
have darker on the invoice to go use if they
want to use it you know this is another
thing people do a lot. They're not supposed
to do with no go on the go on the invoice
and use Docker as a way to like mess with it
so let's give it run to hear you suck I want
to see if it's even there until we see can
we see if it's there I bet it is
it is there so we just have to tell it
yeah it was billed from doctor right I know
so I think we should do Cee and then we
should be explicitly say I don't want to see
him
right so yeah I I feel good about this
extended chassis group
interesting I don't remember that step
I don't remember the sea group staff
that is me being talked about in that bug
bug that you reported their Rihanna you
right I think you
I think I think you give truncated it though
Brioni
I think oh no nevermind reminder run
I'm doing this because I want I want to go
Addison my tutorial or my whatever my notes
all right let's go resistant sale
soap off said it was him
and you must sing a song Ricky Ricardo from
me
yeah I saw that container 81 l b g I already
right now on you I'm trying to decide
whether I want to install just container too
but I actually think I want dr. see you on
because I am I just a second interview down
then I don't have the doctor in point I
don't have the doctor command you know I
mean under using to see this is a receiver
driver oso4 going to use a container t a
from the doctor when we still have to fuck
with his secret and that would not been
accounted accounted for unless you read the
documentation Integrity got it got it got it
yes let's do that okay and then me and my
text browser 90
a lady that fell through we did that sister
to tell Dan that I'm
QT
is there a container you
okay go here we go use assistant to see your
driver system receiver driver with runcie
set you must realize that we start to hear
you again
when running TV manually configure the
secret driver for keyboard
Larry this for second I know you don't need
a girl I know but I want it
because I want to be able to go dig into
their containers and everything on the
system to look and understanding so
I'm sitting here yes I heard this and that
cool toolbox
c c r driver agree CDL does that come with
an L
I bet it is crazy till we see each other the
same as docker interesting
I'm like I'm I can just about ready to throw
out doctor and his cell container T only
is instructions of how to do that
I'm really close to doing that because
canaries the future I mean let's be real
right
I have never used a Christian crickler
Kre-O doesn't work I tried to hurry out and
it doesn't work probably my bad but
yeah I am going to revise my Baker
insulation and use
container tea instead I think this is such a
huge container to use is he right on time
can you cash your pods what
if there's a certified then why the fuck am
I not using alright fuck it fuck Docker
Docker can I have Docker at work but I would
much rather be able to continue and I can be
the first person to get ready to work and
then I can help them yet so I made a Command
Decision I'm going to be shocking this
installation and instead I'm going to go in
here and I'm going to provision
stuff for a doctor c e
but a smart used to tell that interact
directly with the container on time on the
old my God oh my God oh my God
that's awesome so we are going to be this is
all saved and get it so I can go back to if
I need to install Docker container install
Docker container d container tccra
First Energy engine
no you can go away you can go away swap off
has to still be there or send him a stalker
C
no don't need that
and I don't need that I probably don't need
to kick manager at all
I'm doing I miss those down below though so
and there's no doctor stuff at all
anymore it's okay this is awesome
b o c o with
it is such a different kind of curious what
time monkey messenger so I can get around
your system there is that that cool thing
that they do
when they do this
this adds or land that filter
the area has no filter so and I mean to do
that
I don't know why this is being crazy
accounts to I don't know if it's I don't
know if that's needed
it seems like it's redundant to me as like
they're covering the same things in two
places right there most of these houses out
there both models loads
I don't think this is needed I think I may
be able to get rid of it because they're
doing the bridge traffic over here yeah
let's get rid of this this whole section can
go away
alright so
I mean the order isn't matter so
it is a cream sauce packages when are the
key packages as a dependency
you think so oh you take it everything that
the greasy till
yeah let me check regret is a safe troll
oh my God
I was there already absolutely thank you for
saying so why are you not to be happy
oh that's very useful information thank you
very much so
install container the engine
RnB that we had regular mom drove over there
this this is this is what is Jack said he
could come out of it
I got this is from that standard can raise.
So you know when in doubt I I stick with the
cat the committee stuff I don't like the
fuck around with it
just for obvious reasons right so much
trouble right is needs injector drivers in
so this says Etsy module. Load so overly and
B are filled these These are kernel modules
that are either install the packages or that
are available that are not activated I don't
know it doesn't matter though that's what
this is doing this is activating pieces of
the colonel drivers they're not their
drivers zippers in between drivers and the
colonel is super in 4D understand that's why
the rest people can never ever say that Russ
is going to be used for the Linux kernel
it's not the best it will ever be able to do
is to be able to be used as a driver which
can be objecting to the colonel which they
will say is the same and it's not it's
definitely the same in fact Linda Stovall
explicitly said rest will never be in the
colonel even said so in writing
so there we go and get rid of this one
so then we have my Pro here so
tell overlays to find overtime I really need
to write down and cover your guide everybody
does
that's why I'm making a lab for it right
because I at least want to have that
available and go back to it this valuable
information for me for survival 144 other
stuff so this is just container name so are
you down here we set up the the bridges this
is what turns on on a table stuff so that
the Pod networking can work if you for
forwarding and B6 and then we're going to go
ahead and read this is that actually
effectively restarts I think this restarts
to Colonel I think this restarts system is
the system itself reinitialize is it in a
way that keeps I don't know actually
cystocele configured to run time we do not
have this in the 90s I have not done Colonel
ship since night that's the 90s the right
you know hello world, wants us to get get
into a guy want to get a curl programming
and the fact that we even have this till now
just blows my mind I'm super having it to
learn about him
three of you direct me to say Montana I
don't want to give you six I agree I'm just
going to stay with the standard for now I
don't want to talk with anything I will come
back and trim it down as needed some sea
shells used to make room for a run time
promise to be able to listen to Praxis test
is required for a sissy at the city
elsewhere in Lenox that's because everything
talks to that file system by the way PS
everything they talked to the park I'll
system it's super cool everything goes
through the file system when we will say
everything is a file that literally mean it
everything is and I know it's physically you
can use
you can you set some details of the most
read and write to sync them all right so
enough of that
it may be worth it for me to go back and get
it and get it get it get a Linux I like a
modern Linux cert and get hit all the new
basis for the New Lenox to send in stuff
because it's at this point it's so much in
10 years
how do you say something available and if
it's not fair you're probably just feel ya
yeah so here we go we have sister swap off
so that we're not at reprovision this this
week and I'm going to rebuild our entire
cluster
using this we're going to destroy it and I
don't want to reprovision because he's God
because you got Colonel stuff I think I
think I clean the cleanest way to do this is
to do it destroy I just write literally like
Burns all the machines to the ground as if
they never existed and then rebuild it from
scratch rather than try to have it
reprovision I don't trust it so that means
anything or not we're going to be waiting
for a while
vagrant up yeah yeah the whole V6 thing
so this this is again this is vagrant
creating new machines virtual machines
if you don't know what that means you
probably should review the section in the
community site we could go to the
architecture you can read about traditional
server architecture virtualization and then
containerization will this what we doing
right now is virtualization we're creating
virtual servers on which were going to run
communities
and we're using elmaleh Which is higher
percent Santa West compatible and certain
members of the Canadian report it is safer
Scott it only has like a four-day turnaround
time for bug fixes as a pose as security
fixes as opposed to essential as there has
been much slower according to reports
SMS reading for Visions as you go and do a
fresh fish provision when she got everything
working
yeah I've been doing it I haven't I haven't
been doing the yeah when I get a new things
in this case I'm throwing out and I'm
throwing out of thing and adding a new thing
you know so I kind of felt better doing it.
I hear you say I actually was doing that
while I was building bigger and I was like
okay and now of sadness now it said this and
I was just doing that reload except for
vision and it was just keeping it in until
the old stuff was only there is no I'm sorry
already here Services yeah but in but in
this case if I feel like it's a different
Chrome on so Mom probably supposed to be
able to get rid of her running chroma to
know whatever release whatever but it may or
may not be doing it right so
so I mean God we can if we did this right
here it will it will have nothing else to
detect except for container to be in the
whole secrecy thing we did not fuck with the
cigarettes that would be interesting to see
if it does this without having to do the
system be secret fix those just try it
without it
see if it if it doesn't if it gives us the
arable know why
Patrol
all right so it's going to be dmc2 Cube ATM
and it
file Diaz active
because the interface is for talk to the
container on time
Docker is required for container runtime for
XPO file not found a path
and shouldn't need Docker qbdm uses docker I
think this might have been the problem that
they hit
ha
keeping him still because it couldn't find a
dock or executable
it doesn't make any sense
for container runtime exit docker
that means I have to do the dash dash Creole
whenever right
is weird all right I didn't read all the
information and I'm an idiot
I didn't read all this I didn't do all this
I didn't do a container to you in all this
yeah I only I stopped stopped I need to know
the rest of the stuff
I get it cuz I didn't even make I didn't
shoot to set up at all so it's like it's a
Dirty Heads vacation official document
puzzle restrictions are sending.
Okay well what wait a second here apparently
you have to do it
it says you can have this reception jeans
Community has free run time like a mess
opportunity on your system install and
configure X got you install container d
from an extra power sell it so I can hear
you got a package from the official dock
revolves
I didn't do that I did not
respect a Linux distribution stalling
container Dio package can be found
shit so I do have to do that package install
huk you have it
this is how we'll know
I just got it it's got it it just doesn't
know which one to use
I guess I did install Xfinity package no I
didn't I drop to the other doctor package
and I did to The Container to package
but I don't want to do Dr Ste I want to do
container to you without it you know I mean
this page is easier read like this a man
sent to us
M remove ice all over jeans yeah I did this
right thing I don't want to sucker
installation methods Umatilla seem
intelligent Cafe manager Saturday
this is really convoluted so if I want to
use container d
I have to use extra steps anyway cuz it said
so look
it said
all right so then it says to install
container d
it's in the container. IO package from the
official doctor depositories
all right so so that means we still need to
do that same stuff all right I had to get us
to do
I know what to do we need
we need to add back what I had here before
that's just the doctor repo but we but when
do you need to replace docracy with with
container that you can hear you that I owe
if that's a package I'm hoping it is so we
still have to have these lines right here
and I mean
yeah we still have to have these lines
when I when I get to the doctor but yeah
and it's a dependency of doctor seeing which
is West was it
docracy need music when I really want to do
is I don't want to install as I have to
and I mean so I want to get that I want to
eat like zoom in on the back of his head
that I think I am the only packages I need
condemning
did I not do that right yes I suck I suck
actually am cuz I need to learn this damn
thing that has your address to fill all
right
we just need to repo in order to get the
stuff I mean
all right so we do this because I see do you
know what was it called
I got it I got it over this config imperfect
manager
add repo alright so
we still need to add it and then we need to
add
we just need to do yeah after you had a repo
well I don't even know I think you take your
right yeah
I mean yeah it was all right so then we do
if there is no video sounds like her
set Nest to 70 so we're going to be doing
container tea and actually this stuff is all
in the container to the docks I know this
isn't anything there
I think container gave me that I owe
I mean that's what it said and if I trusted
that's what it says
it's on the container. IO package
two and then configure container to you and
these steps are
Destiny Beyond yes
yeah we can do all these steps as we go
right now that's that's normally how I do
anyway let me know what to do reprovision
right so so the Alice Through the 7th
yeah I I need you to say my so is my
daughter
city of I'm going to remember this young
package manager
add repo
config manager Emmett I'm trying to do you
have to recall config
Bethel okay then
am update
and then we're going to need to do you have
a second area if I can see you and Ash Why
install tnrd that I owe
it looks like it's doing it
and then we had the configuration steps
I know I feel like this is extra stuff
I don't park comes first you know
alright so how's it going the right thing to
do. Look at all the steps
sounds of Genesis right so 7
cinema Christian it security
why does it make us do our own configuration
config default sq32 config. Tunnel
I wish I could hear you
and I feel like I won't ever going to do
this but
yeah I think it might already be there at 2
I was going to say yeah if you could
so yeah I have a feeling it's already there
sometimes it do that actually they were done
in Asia exterity
Terre di ya see it's already there I don't
know if it's already there because the stuff
we did after that
or ever the stuff that I did that got
installed with the thing you know
I feel like I was at me. We won't know until
we do the permit for trash but I feel like
the package did that
so I feel like that stuff is unnecessary so
let's give it another shot
yeah you just insulted Sunshine so
but what I find interesting is it it still
says to do that it says inside the container
t i a package and then do this well I can
hear your package just put it there a no-sew
Community config default
is there any come here I have a feeling this
is already there
I don't know that I'm going to approve it
but I feel like it's already there yep it is
so don't need to do it so that was some bad
docs there
check the secret stuff yet for sure so did
you do that didn't you do that since he's
already start getting ready and this is
probably better as a as a naval Dash. Now
it's funny cuz that consistency in the
stocks is not as good as the other one
started macaron accidents
I feel like we need to I just want to see
something cgl
status container d I think Sarah is actually
disabled
inactive so
I mean as soon as I can figure a she's we
wanted this should be
City of Cincinnati L enable that shows now
community
and that should give us a nice happy
container d
nice I feel a pretty little tree in pretty
little container G
I don't have it went somewhere else with my
neighbor
I am lazy but ever see this
question do I still have darker probably not
no docker nice I feel happy
all right so we have integrity running and
it's in the prisoner thing fine and next
step
we check on this on the on the group's right
and
I mean that's done
I don't have any way here we go to be secret
driver
Jesus has to be secret driver in Tamil with
runcie set Bubba Bubba if you apply does
change make sure we started here again do
you how can we know that what was the error
message message was
I mean can't we just check to see what how
much money was for Missions are
I should be in the status actually Loaded
Lux
we can use this in a fig the problems with
the front lines were running a system be
right
Auntie Fee if we're going to compare these
stuff and it is said to not cigarettes
assisted is such a docker
let me know I have a problem right got it
let's do that so it's going to its container
do you configure a tunnel I mean the logo
I made the time 11 I have committed it going
to say that every day I get tired of hearing
you say disabled plugins
anywhere would even be it doesn't even look
like it's in here yeah I feel like I feel
like it's worth it explicitly adding it
you know what I mean it's like it right here
in plugins getting ready
I can you run time to run to see
a b c y z remove it from
disable plugins why would we disable the
Cherry plugin isn't it the one we need
is in command I know that might be why they
did it huh
I see this is starting to make sense
actually listen to the output of that and
see what happens yeah let's see what that
looks like shall we
let's take a look
oh my God alright so we need those steps we
definitely need those steps
9 m
cuz it's use my doctor yes and so they said
we don't need it
message default yeah okay that makes sense
we don't even make the directory but we do
need to do this
that is required. How much it is root by the
way
wait since I laid you is rude it is right
here
and if I can pick it should be enabled
that's what I think too that's why we don't
have to redo it it'll already be enabling
their yeah agreed agreed
I read it read read all right so
I'll do that will go ahead and sell this
we're going to do this and
then we're going to enable kanuni renamed
what
it has ever been enabled so you know is she
still be an active so let's do
yeah I suppose there so we could do let's
try this is try a North case has orange
juice to substitute ELD no
restart container d
I don't know how we would validate it
I really don't but I know that's it let's
just do as status statues
hey look starting Auntie runtime happy it is
it looks very happy to me does it not
see if you're selling yourself Secret is
that your bet you're betting on the secret
thing huh
alrighty do that
there it is right here system secret false
that has to be true dammit we're going to
write a said thing
I'm going after my dad said thing because
this is got to be
is that I can handle it but I don't want to
I still said it
and also sections sections yeah I know I saw
that if that's where I am right now
so if you register service
Sol Cocina runtimes runcie
system secrecy was true and actually there's
more than this
I think it's
Journey run times
is there any run sometimes. Runcie hi there
turning the fall run time shit
Ariane container T run times run C
runtime engine temporary privileges host
system secret because true
I don't see it meant to add it God damn it's
damn it's a lot of configuration
system secret membership I feel like there
was another setting up above we could have
said the changes easier
oh right well there's nothing there
run times right in front of the options
right now container to run X run see two
options
I feel it's just it's just a different
package repository install crew package done
is it really
now I pray that we had problems like for you
this should not be this painful
do you think male doctors never going to do
that because they're they're motivated to
keep dark around their so they're not going
to they're not they're not motivated today
to make it easier to install container you
separately
we we had to make a number of configuration
changes do that
this is really really esoteric change and
it's really weird ambiguous
Jesus system Gigi Series driver
why wouldn't she was a system receiver
driver under what conditions would you not
do that I'm used to give me a minute I can
figure secret forever Kingwood
what that does not make me happy
yeah
I don't know why it has mixed case like that
that's kind of freaking me out
I I feel like it might be old data
also this is going to be a pain in the ass
to add as we have to do a crazy ass said
thing to get this there
and I mean
is it a secret by default I don't think it's
going to
but I mean I'm going to do something like
bad that we know we need to add the secret
thing right but I want to try it without it
because I may not be needed
she looks systemd starting container tea
container runtime I feel like it doesn't
need it
I feel like something about this is old and
it's working now
I can prove it though I mean is running on
your system be started without no problems
and then tell you what is running as pretty
sure to fall The Secret FS
how do we know if you look at the running
process we can't write because it's this
shit she owns or whatever
I'm saying what I have a key for men
I'm done
I guess you would know is tuna in it
will know right
so far it's so good
I mean I didn't provision the other ones but
I need a keyboard on this system should be
fine I didn't restart the key with though
I wonder if I need to restart a key but I
probably do yeah
oh my God it's working it's only working it
didn't need it
it didn't need it hahaha that's good news
that is wonderful news
it is wonderful news that this works without
anything else
right so long story short because darker and
container to your married at the hip
Thrift we just one container d i o
we have to say Hey you remember that default
can hear this shit that's designed to work
early one with darker that we don't want
when we want to blow all that out and we
wanted make a container to config and we'll
just enable that
this this is beautiful to me the fact that
that works is absolutely beautiful to me we
just got our first our first I know this is
Success because I've seen this before I've
done this before so this is how you do the
join my super secret token
I know I have to go do
I hate that I have to go copy and paste a
shit though which I'm probably going to get
wrong actually no we can do it from this
machine I mean
would you rather put that on our on our on
our other notes right now
oh my God I'm a take a break after this I
have a very good feeling thank you so much
LV gdn
this is been very helpful I really
appreciate it hopefully other people have
benefited from learning all this as well
and then we need to put the rest on the end
of this
set 8 I don't know what to do here
Sudoku by the way this is why I need you
made him on the nose as well
get know I'd that's a thing when I'm done it
yet
do you think it already checked in I thought
I had to do a joint first
I don't think I need to join my friend so I
don't think the joint works because I didn't
get the whole token in
and I'm saying
little panels up but
any number of organized by rain is falling
ever so you saying
do they control play note is up I got you
yes
refuse Mike the Knight
I don't know about the sexual thing that
you're doing I never done that
oh because you can't use that cake of a k
yeah I just sent him directly by the phone I
got you
I know something that's new information to
me but thank you so much for that
I can't open the confirmation died Ikea near
me
recessional I probably spelled wrong
God damn I didn't realize it was locked down
that hard I didn't realize it was like I
mean it's just it's got keys and shit in
there
yeah
yeah that that's guys like all kinds of keys
inserts of shity right yeah that's like it's
supposed to be locked out and I don't know
that's like my first time seeing if I'll
this is great this is so great I can't tell
you
it's supposed to rain
I know I'm smart now I finished finally like
oh why is it saying not rude readable
because it's got the whole Keys of the
Kingdom in it
that would be very bad now I know what to
attack estate sale
get now damn
probably they're wrong again Syracuse City
Hall get no
get nodes I am Wonder
Maybe I didn't didn't didn't do the port
forward no she doesn't think you're right
see this I'm at that yeah so
thanks for this thing here Hugh
and warms my heart
it warms my heart that's right because we
can cuz I was going to ask if I had to had
to run join the thing about join the thing
about join is only for the stuff you have to
do on the other nose right so this is really
important that I take a note of this if you
wanted to test whether your nose are
actually working start with and knowed you
know the worker note are the node that's on
your current control plane system because
that's the one that's already there right
and then you can go in and join other stuff
right
and watch it while adding nodes oh my God so
you can actually do it I do know why should
we do watch without the W I know that
there's a difference between the two
so we can do cubes ETL
I got an 0-0 wide that's dope to be for
watch and then we're just going to sit here
and watch the other notes come on do I need
to copy and paste that other thing is just
some of the way I can get it I guess there
is I'm off the time off that you try to go
back to go back to the store so I can
remember the steps here but I'm happy I have
a cluster of a cluster of one have a cluster
of one right now
that we built our very own selves
yeah I had a drink then I think you can
actually get the joint command
there's a way to export it and I I don't
remember so
how to get the join command from Cube ATM
for a new
Journey communities token list
Duncan create hey Ben shenkman there it is
and also generate token in for the drink
imagine
I got it right here this one right here
right here to Minto can you create
project like this probably easier if I if I
forgot your phone is right yeah it's not bad
if you do it right it's just a new token you
throw it away if you can use the one and it
just gave me the comedians but this is going
to like hey this is not bad to redo so so
so
yeah but it has to be done from the from the
module so vagrant SSH
oh does it it has a 24 hour delay or teach
you how nice that's cool because I mean
obviously you're going to have a new workers
going to a damn right you can listen with
you so I can say I saw that control
I'm going to run this what does your cat
poops
and there we go zoom in on that and, that's
it
I look for you because I was going to run it
through excellent
and I can do I get SSH and over yeah I could
sap
until this is a vagrant thing I don't I'm
not sure about the house
I just about to have a side piece if I did a
just do this is Asian with her
which I probably should do actually I should
probably set up password of 60 seconds
between the master and the and the notes
free ministration purposes I know it's got a
security risk to do that
you know when people are positioned directly
into the
we're going to the nodes you can do that
mean there's any number of ways you could go
back to me for security though I kind of
feel like forcing people to SSH into the
master control plane and then a sensation
for the company and other things is never
quite as you have to have connectivity to
those things so so that would be a reliable
way to do it for so that you would really be
locking it down right
I mean if there's argument against that as
well as arguments against just a lot of
people this addition to the nodes in points
and not to the control plane and just let
him go in there there are access to your
underlying a host systems what would you
feel the most comfortable giving them if
you're if you're the community's
administrator everything communities person
who what are you most obviously refers to be
going to have route to everything usually if
you're going to have some sort of you know
centralized ldap like Administration or
login so
so either one is a thing but I do not put
that in my in my notes are because that is a
consideration that
I am probably putting here consider
setting up SSH login from control to
no one two nodes
the reason I like doing that is because in
if you want to run like non keyword and his
administrative stuff Central he say you
wanted to run an ansible under control plane
you could if you wanted to write
do any kind of troubleshooting fixing
absolutely
yeah I know it seems like
it is I haven't really looked on he was
input on this because
I mean look if somebody if somebody has
access if somebody has access to your
control plane as route you're fucked
that's why I'm not sold on taluswood because
of the whole checking everything out just
give it a try
you don't you don't have a mystery or access
to it at all right
but it's supposed to save you from all that.
So you're not supposed to have to get that
means you have to use to raise the
management
yeah
but I think so wait I got it I got to I got
to ponder this thing I probably want to be
some coffee we have a successful no login
and I know exactly how to get the other
workers to work so I'm not worried at all I
feel like I'd like we have success we
haven't reprovisioned everything but all the
stuff that we just did is in the provision
script so we're good to go but I really do
is I want to I want to just brainstorm the
best security architecture for this
at. Phuc yea
yeah who you can't there's nothing you can
do to fix it you're completely dependent on
it on a on a black box solution I so you're
saying you can't even get on there to debug
anything you couldn't you couldn't you
couldn't even get yeah that might you know
what I say I hear what you're saying because
in a perfect world in a perfect world he
wouldn't have to get on a note and see
what's up you know why is there in our
problem here or whatever right but we don't
live in a perfect world is all kinds of
things you can fuck up what's happening on
saying it could probably going to diagnose
something that might beat else's fault how
we're going to eliminate that we have no way
of getting on the underlying system of doing
that without short of right writing Damon
set or some shit like that that would run on
the endpoint that's like multiple levels of
complexity I guess I guess the reality check
I've been having is
you have two architectures that are ghetto
fundamentally intertwined one that's highly
dependent on the other one you have your
deployment of hosts obviously you're the
machines and you have your community's
deployment as a nose and those things are in
our case for example they're managed by two
separate groups completely two separate
groups
is it in the back to Spain Point here to pay
Baker Imaging and put on bigger called for
this why not I probably should if they're
not already one there I definitely will I
didn't I didn't
I didn't I didn't know that I could add
bacon Cloud stuff but I think I will
because he'll if we did that they're going
to do vagrant up right and we can get the
whole thing and then we can go in there and
fuck around to visit as a training tool
I'm all about that all about that I'm all
about that that's like that's like that's
like what I was going to do with containers
and darker for in a teaching programming and
stuff you know what the individual
containers
yeah I mean I know it can be done I haven't
done this is like my third day or they
aren't but so my next question is would you
buy into arcade Attica mimic setups I don't
I don't know I don't know I don't have
enough information on that
I think I searched Frederick two races you
find some you just find Sakura days for
minors that to this
yeah I look at him some pictures all in one
for the volume based on Damien stretch yeah
I know way I want mine to be based on Alma I
bet there's no Alma here at all
wait what about me there's no Alma here
yeah I'm definitely to add my own I am I I
am really sold on this
miniature want to fuck now
Mini Cooper already has cameras installed
why would you make that a okay
hell yeah I got it I got to do this 21
then just a doctor communities yeah
this I'm so happy I stuck with vagrant and
we got it to work with the liver and shit
there's some set yeah they're sent to us
you're such a mess I bet you there's no Alma
at all I bet you anything
these are four years old these images are
like 45 years old Hawk
God damn it we got it we got to publish
these people I'm going to publish this and
keep it up to date
I mean great stuff from Vape people but
five years ago Richard Lux images none of
them delivered and my stuff's all libert
God damn we really have to publish this I
didn't realize how I'm covered this stuff
was
yeah single kid version right
yeah it match car they are killing it now oh
my God yeah I want to work for hash of
course so bad I I'm going to say it right
now my next job jump I'm going to shoot with
everything in my power to go to a corner
haschak or is kicking ass I would be really
surprised if I bet you redhead tries to buy
them
I bet I be in the red hat they got gobs and
gobs and gobs and gobs of money I bet they
go for it but they try to buy them
the thing is I don't think they'll ever go
for it because they're so unique and no
do you like Microsoft no way I don't think
that they would go for it it would have to
be a hostile takeover
yeah it would totally have to be a hostile
takeover because they look like their
product line the haschak or ethos does not
play with others
it's like oh that's the International Center
okay great we're going to make a better one
we who need your fucking converted he's
trying to let you know they sold needs to be
redone if you ask me but that's not
happening they're going to invest all the
time to reform everything else
it is getting interesting to see because
ansible and someone tell her former partner
going to start overlapping even more on
ansible is crazy amazing oh my God I love
and support the red hat thing now Aaron has
a total control the colonel
who is going to be really scary as if
redhead bought hash Corp that would be
scared I would be really scary it's it's
definitely a possibility
I didn't bother him absolutely right hats
the rent it to use l live in
so do that I've been thing
and then the guy left yeah he left he was
didn't let me know presidents and they made
some other guys to do it some weird I be a
maternal shows it and then they and then
they had and he left that little earlier if
I'd had left
that's the last I heard of it I haven't been
following it there's this quite a bit of
drama over there but suffice it to say
redhead has got the Enterprise Linux Market
pretty much locked up
let me know if there's no I don't I don't
think there's any serious debate about that
I'm not talking about container OS is I'm
talking about hostesses host OS Linux
Sunday Night Vision Plus unlimited money I
know I can't believe I did that
when did they do that they didn't Activision
purchase go down last week or something I
missed it
if I get it for 7 bill it does only 7
billion though
they bought Minecraft for nine billion that
my Club Penguin for 7 billion to nowhere
was it three days ago I didn't hear I heard
Lila activity I didn't realize it was
Microsoft about them 70 bill that's got to
be the biggest purchase ever that's like
that's like
Nvidia purchasing arm kind of thing like
money it's insane
I like Disney buying Star Wars money what
was that does like I was nine or ten billion
I think
Partridge Hanceville Al yeah
I know I'm super happy cuz everything's
working
and we absolutely do need to put a vagrant
out there Golden Child thank you for saying
so
thank you for saying such a Golden Child
that's pronounced productive I'm going to
give Golden Child VIP for the day VIP
rotates case you're wondering everybody so
if you ever if you one day we lose your VIP
I'm sorry it's only because
I can give people the IP for their
contributions to Natsu my way of reporting
I'm really glad that I realize that because
that that way I can like we're more people
daily for their contributions and and then
and then it just wrote it down and then the
most active people give VIP and by active I
mean they are contributing to the stream in
a good way in a way that literally cost me
would have cost me time and energy so
this is crazy I I okay so let's think about
this architectural decision here that we
haven't risen point to make before we go off
into la-la land in Funland and it exploded
into the gaming industry yeah
I guess because it's too much about me ask
if they buy OverWatch
Microsoft has always been best at gaming and
gaming is nothing
I'm surprised it in by twitch it makes more
sense for them to buy toys in Amazon
I think it's cuz I didn't want to get into
streaming they have no streaming platform at
all on my Microsoft Amazon is the only
accept me then
oh no hell no perfect purchase with which it
is so smart
we're going to leave anyways other notes yes
I have one question I want to ask so why
is it safe to setup passwordless root SSH
access by using keys from the control planes
to the nodes and I believe the answer is yes
I believe the answer is yes
I'll see the joint Jones then no joints
and I'm going to I'm going to ask that
question in a broader audience probably on
our podcast Day on Sunday and I'm a see if
we can get some more industry Security
Experts in
I I think that that is as secure as
you could expect
if your if your control planes if someone
gain root access to your control planes
control play nodes you're fucked your 100%
fully fuck your whole Enterprise is fucked
because
because by doing that they can get access to
your secrets and everything else you still
in recovery is closer so
saying that root access to the
do the control play nodes is of Paramount
importance is like an understatement and it
also means that anybody with that access
already can hack into any one of your notes
by creating a demon set that that fires up a
backdoor any kind of shit like that so it's
there so I'm putting a you just making it
easier by allowing them to SSH into your
making your life easier because because you
can like basically open the hood of your
communities cluster and poke around without
getting your fingers chopped up by the
engine
we just can you watch running you can
actually go watch the engine while it's
running and do all this thing so if you can
imagine yourself into the head into the
control planes and messaging around into any
of your notes from that jumping off point
and then you can monitor you can manage
access by managing access to your control
planes any of your administrator should have
SSH access to control planes and if they do
they can do all kinds of God awful horrible
things but they already could that's what a
job there traffic to blush it up and fix
things right that's an admin Sue so I
believe I believe this step here is
Justified but I'm going to leave it up here
for discussion
I think we should probably disable disable
password
login to
I just say it's probably easiest I think it
is to yeah
make Bastion or jump box with cedar wrapped
install yeah the time Google Thedacare
yep
you make every pod and no secure
Jenny controller yep yep
well the jump box the jump box is going to
be the thing that gets you into everything
the reason I want to bring this topic up is
because I don't know how this jives with
zero trust tell me what is written papers on
zero trust on this kind of thing and I don't
that's not a zero trust environment so
that's why I'm wondering I'm wondering how
that works
gem boxes of like that I don't know where
they fit in zero trust right so I would
rather model as it was supposed to burn if I
can and
see what that looks like I think what that
means is
we would have to provide a credential fall
or Edmonds to every single system like
granularly but that's going to remove all
kinds of abilities for Automation and stuff
that's really the whole this pick up the
stuff I'm saying the stem cells into a
bigger much bigger conversation by zero
trust an admin if if you know what if I put
danceable one of them an answer when I
control plane
probably not a good idea it's really fun
dancing wanted your phone but it in a small
environment and a small environment putting
putting ansible on that one so you can voice
up to your to your notes quickly a week week
and it was angered by just read provisioning
but if you were if you were at relatively
small to mid-sized company and you didn't
want to have more than one thing I mean you
could chance it when ansible anywhere near
control planes you want those to be all by
themselves and that ansible danceable
launching sting to be on its own server so
what I'm trying to do is I'm trying to I'm
trying to match the architectures of
you know a number of a virtual machines in a
physical machines and then a number of
either of
either of those things that have been
allocated to communities and then kind of
create the boundaries between them all in
terms of like accessibility how do you get
to them and you know what is the security
boundaries between because because that's
kind of the that's the whole infrastructure
part right
self is there Arquette and zhen step access
comes in a painful for automation yeah
yeah yeah yep I'm getting ahead of myself I
mean I just in a single customer excited
because we're so that's actually go let's go
actually go join a node
so I already have one I think I already have
one
Arizona listen to
what the hell oh wait now we're on the Run
thing wait where am I where am I
alright so here's guitar playing and have to
control planes
I got to
log control plane and what's this guy
all right here we go yeah tell Ken
damn it 9 token
or
in one
and then my Discovery token CA cert hash
Shaw
the old Colonel doing I'm running I think it
is
I mean it was the latest one from from
vagrants generic
I whoops
join
so do we get a new node
control Clean Master container G 90s
invalid value of derp
Derpy derp
comedian showing I forgot the
I forgot the part
long
keeping it I want with container t
I will add a container to you on there and
got rid of darker
yep and ended the Falcon the gracian work
for sure I was really happy about
Docker is required for container runtime
so are nodes are nodes are fucked up because
they don't have to change the over here so
yeah we're going to have to I'm going to I'm
going to drop we're going to drop the whole
vagrant and restart it now that we have all
over provisioning because the other nodes
don't have to take her to
don't have integrity on them right you
betcha
yeah I know we did a lot of provisioning by
hand to see if it was working with coughing
in the provision file my hand you know so I
assume this is going to go work oh wait what
the fuck alright this is crazy okay I need
to add the thing here
just for container we need to make sure that
that is clear
and we go over here and get the kids ready
have you heard this this is the only way to
do that was really that made me really happy
because I was given the documentation how
many how many problems will be fine with it
with it with the documentation several
the cell I'm super happy about this oh yeah
what should I do should I get the new kernel
should we do a different to go get the
kernel of directly
actually I think there is another cloud
that's I think that's just a generic one
Cloud search Elmo
I think that's just the way I think I think
there's another I think there's another Alma
image of his more recent kernels
there it is
so I'm using generic 8 and this is goddamn
that's like a lot more frequent in recent
this is got three thousand in the spring of
somebody on the 8th instead I told you I'm
at 8
what kernels is how do we even know that I
guess I have to just try it
actually let's just do it
how much is Alma 8 instead
I want to see 8 all right
vagrant destroy
hello there you Jensen needs to repair its
report or just take a break I'm going to go
start this provisioning and then I'm going
to take a quick break I need to kind of walk
around for a bit talk to my wife
go for lunch I kind of want to go for a walk
hey you want to go for a walk did you
already do that
oh it's raining dinner do you know what
wants to go for you know what though did she
get her you know what
did the dog get her you know what did the
dog get get one
yeah
all right I got to figure this song
So if I said if I said
do we really need to change it an FS tab
I mean we can
oh here we go will you you didn't run time
in Cuba have probably called secret driver
imagine if you can rent a vacuum approve
drivers require otherwise a cube of process
will fail
darker secret virus it's the same from. Like
rotation or just his container which is what
we did see you at
new religion start
hang out I think
that one off I am cleaning everything of
gimme a Break
alright so onto
no he needs to run and it on
on control
to add the first to create a control plane
and create the first node
local it's noisy I know
I think she's making something good some
good food
nobody commits this anymore done I'm going
to go ahead and bring her and destroy this
that I do that
and you already I think I did all right so
I'm going to pick her up this and I think
it's done I think the whole thing is done so
and then I'll be able to take a break if you
can take a while to run so I might walk away
from it
vagrant up
Levert provider, Lennox is going to download
it right I'll turn this off since it's noisy
I'll be back
all right well I thought a car yep I bought
a car
another Subaru sorry I'm eating
espresso beans hey look at work
all right let's do this sh vagrant
Marin SSH into
Maria connect to
all the way
let's see
let's see what we're going to do today I am
so happy it's all working
control and Soo do
tbdm Annette
not just too long getting the doctor shit
again
my Zoomer dog right that we got rid of that
I got rid of the doctor said
what do we have to do here
let's see
I think I'm missing something it was working
and now it's not God damn it
congrats on your face used to talk to The
Container once I measure doctors are car
from Cheer what time is Yankees a darker you
still think it's using docker
I think about it still think of using Docker
I don't know why it was his container to you
I think that's the thing we spent the most
time we can figure in right it's got to be
something that we missed
let's go see if well we'll see if Cantera
team got installed
I bet you that's right I bet you're right I
met you right
synergy
it doesn't return is already started yeah I
think that's probably it
yeah I'm feeling a file is fine other than
that I have no idea about it it doesn't even
know what it is and where it has been
installed yet
way to be remade
that's weird I think it didn't even did it
not here
I don't I don't think anything 00
did my stuff break it
uh-oh spaghettio
yeah
that's why you were trying to remember a
typing
yes
you know what am I don't think it has um
configuration manager that's what's up
yeah that's what broke it yeah well that's
good to know by the way
covid-19 what's the most recent colonel
doesn't seem like a lot newer yeah
yeah that's that's sucks so how many of the
latest colonel
I don't want to have to actually make our
own
I mean hopefully amusing it is supposed to
be more recent and up-to-date than the other
ones
I don't want to pack a template I know a
pack of us we could probably know I feel
like they're pushing Packer over over
vagrant
this is way behind yeah they usually are are
the truth of the matter is is it that is the
same as red head so
yeah
let's do that let's see if that fixes if
that if that fixes it then I mean we change
some things without testing them
without testing them and that's probably
something we should pull back on I'm going
to change anything else in the repo
except that we go back to the El Metate what
you've already got the images for so we
shouldn't it should be a problem
and
the fragrance of my watch it this time
persistence and perseverance Ave Denville
yeah
yeah I know I kind of want to keep I don't
want to cross the streams again I've been
trying to use protection tools as developer
tools and got in trouble with David
terraform
probably just you know hit unnecessary
blocks unrequited I do want to come back to
terraform and start using it once I get
proxmox setting it set up or whatever it
takes to build my own cloud here
but that's that's a ways away especially
since we just dropped seven Grand on a new
car today or just punched a new car today
for 7 Grand cash
yeah tinnitus
it's fine it's it's not a beautiful we
decided to make this our junker and then
keep the other one we got the Subaru
Forester we have any other Subaru moving to
a place to sell four-wheel drive Snow
Country cell
am I just be me probably me every
performance and Fitness
oh God
I need a soldier if you do stuff it is
hello I said to send link
what's in the ceiling car
I see alright let's try the next thing
2 2 2 2 2 2 2
do do do do do do
what the hell alright so
what do we got to hear
I think I did a fine big rents I whoops
comedian and it's very simple command that
just doesn't work unless you're going to do
I don't know why I keep forgetting
god dammit oh that's working
everything is just in the pool I just got
the spiral do you want to get always throws
me
looks happy so far
did yoga
give him a doctor on your team all
developers they are impressed Brioni awesome
that is awesome that is super awesome hey
look keep it even worked haha
ask for Etsy God damn it asked for a cube
config
and see Cube Butternut this admin
Cave City El get nodes we have nodes on the
plane
commanding the input and output as well as a
yes I do is there a here I didn't see that
excetera excetera
I said an appointment to make sure home Cube
copy admin at home
shown that I don't think you can just do
this
I should go to play app onto the cluster
what do you think about me already having
fun at work
Venom Energy has a default part Network I
think we need to do that right
begin the training but workers it says I
can't unless I join workers I
it doesn't do the vault working on
we haven't had one yet we're going to eat
right now but we did it we did it earlier
and it works fine so
but if only I know she and I we we wait is
anybody can talk to each other
I'm not sure about that no 21
so
composite be able to talk to each other know
so you can join those with the pods can't
talk to each other and tell you it's Unite
so we probably want to take the time to do
the sea and INR provisioning
I see the notice not ready I noticed not
ready because you can't talk
yeah yeah I Cube
describeI have I don't have compression
which is costing me node
starting keep you updated when I get home
best fishing PD is this for sure
it feel like I see
Irish house is wide and now this messy I
mean if it's cuz I just have a c s i
a critical sauce There we go I'm done
I just says are the rolls at age can you
stack the stuff looks familiar
AI Calica I'm even talking about that one of
these Calico or me calculus one of the
default see and eyes right
they got couches the one that most people
recommend it there there's actually another
one now there's another newer one that's it
supported by I can't remember the name of it
though
yeah so it's on the most used probably yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
let me guess you ladies comes by default I
know which one we use
what's a query to check your seeing-eye is
it actually see and I I got it is
I think I have a Mini Cooper anything up
right now
and they do yeah yeah I didn't look it up
Q I know I know CS scores George Casas have
a thing
probably be in it was it get resources Avi
and you make my thing
q c c l
get on is it only says yeah
that's one thing that's the sachet
yeah that's why there's another one there's
another one that gets like all the resource
center
Cardenas has a built-in compressor a
Cornelius I can check as soon I
sap resources yeah that's the one yeah she
already know if that's the one
and then sapr
I had to get complacent cuz I remember it
Dia networking communities
hey I was doing just fine on that or
whatever
k edits
can cats
not working. What is it there is no ceiling
it how would you even tell it was just you
know that's all I'm asking I guess
yeah I know that but I'm pretty
what I'm trying to do is I'm trying to think
about how I'm going to go to a system that
already has a seeing eye and look at what
when he uses so
is
I can if I if I'm diagnosing assistant I
come in and I think I don't know anything
about the cluster and nobody knows anything
about the closer cuz or last guy died or
something how would I go in and know it's
you know they have you know
a deposit keep system usually there yes yeah
they're they're not because they're not
working
and I would be for an on Princeton tuition
so the Sienna has provided by the cloud
isn't the reason I wanted you on print stuff
and get somebody's wondering
as Calcutta damacai4d apple right
Heritage Park Community Medicaid challenge
as expected for district
so I pause a little communication Spotify
Communications by the service this I know
alarm clock people that use other people to
use graze in the cloud have no idea about
their seeing eye because they'd sell Milton
there's got to be a way to get to see you
tonight it's got to be a way to see which
one implemented
these all offer CNA
I mean it's a resource type is it not I
guess it's not
that's kind of stupid they should have made
a better resource type it with nodes
you know notes haven't met a resource that
you can check them in addition to like
having an actual known
at that fights fucking horrible so I can
hear images running across the roof
San Andreas can I take Alka Scenic thing on
Grace culture
is it possible to directly exposed to
passport a certain reports I saw you from a
new idea of living scanner
methody
oh it's not listed there
well that's annoying that's right about that
that's super annoying I want to come back to
that issue
yeah I saw them I saw the Pod Network cidr
thing is that uses a faulty night I have a
feeling it does
I swear to God there's a default she and I
you're telling me there's not though
guy that's a pain in the ass
we have to decide you have to sell and
storage class too and you have to just go
a well another one time we know we got to be
a solid obviously has to be installed it's
online now
what did I start spotting a thing that does
install it Anthony the Calico stuff right
it's like
did the Sienna is deployed is the point is
it it's it's supposed to Damon said right it
depends it depends on whatever okay for me
to write isn't that though
and I mean
I need I need to find out what she and I
were using to work I got to go do a little
bit of digging
I have to figure out when Cindy and I were
using I don't know I should know I feel bad
that I don't so I'm going to be away from it
I think that I think it might be a seal
does it still provide a c and I
yeah it's just a mess it's just a service
Mission an Ingress and all that jazz it's
got a lot in there right by was wondering if
they include include this year and I in it
Odysseus and I plug in
how's it going Sue's zoos 58
enhancing is CSR smash with a cni plug-in
that would be a no
yeah I know about calico assassin was
wondering I was wondering if it was
I was alright I was worried I was wondering
if the if the cni it was a reason I did read
some instructions about how to replace C&I
before and put it in your communities so and
in trying to determine which Step comes
first when clearly you can deploy a iPod C&I
after you do it but in the committee's
documents they have you do that up front
because when you do your net you need to
know what your pod network ID CID R is if
you're going to use a pot thing so I think
we should probably use you in it with the
Pod Network and rather than use the default
because that information is going to be
provided to
so I'm saying it kind of says you don't need
a podcast Network
we don't work with Calico you don't care
about the phone network
if I network is just how big of a network
you want for all of your pods right that's
just yeah
it just works as a default is probably way
to go then
yeah I tried that we were able to get it we
haven't we still haven't been able to get
want to join so let me let me do that
and it's not because it says have a network
connection is the first things first let me
back up a bit and
let's do this let's do get
yeah I know I guess so
which way is this member which one is this
this is war trying to join and I kind of I
kind of blew away the
kind of blew away the the thing I was
working on cuz I wanted to message you in a
bit so we need to redo this under the join
command
what is it that Jesse Owen yeah we probably
need it
I didn't
never says best by default everybody
we people are dizzy show
we do game here but right now we're just
doing other stuff
yeah they do not have the same hostname or
not supposed to anyway
yeah I need to do they definitely do I try
to give them individual who sings it bigger
and it didn't work
it didn't work I couldn't get it to take
one thing at a time okay so
you know I got a couple things as a
provision so so yeah
I guess we'll just Calico how much are the
Calico in here
alphabet in the provisioner only two big
changes to the original this time we run it
is
using using the other image busted it so I'm
not want to do that
they can file every other game Maria Jose
I remember Hornet Angie though
what is he and I I can use for a CNA
I guess you have a cigarette
Jim Jim Jim qcpl access I guess that's what
she said Jim to see tell access to the to
the control plane before you run qaq ATM in
it I guess you do right
it's just on the same system to talk to you
not to make any sense it's okay so
all right
install security
there is nothere is no spoon exactly
I'm trying to say so
Mariana so above container d
I don't like tutorial because that actually
covered it hey I mean
Rene's
it's like a braces appointment tools
I saw like you're ready and we did this
already I wish they do this a better
you can achieve great customer page all
right we did all this
I just let you know after I thing I mean if
you
a white cat you've been so so helpful
already I don't really want to attack your
time anymore then then necessary I am I have
no problem like struggling through this is
figuring this out on my own but I super
appreciate it
is it giving you a crate that minimum viable
creators cuz there how's it going
pause when how you are how are you paged
pays doing Pace doing
3dm
there's a section to hear about how to set
up the sea tonight and I'm going to go do
that right now so we can focus on this
tonight
I think I think it did and I am
overwhelmingly grateful for your help but I
mean I don't still don't want I want to be
cognizant of your time I don't want to use
it so Evergreen Square container images
going to give me without even a connection.
That just lets you control plane Justified
Network see how they did that they said
say before he did also are in points what
you're going to do later we don't need this
is so since she was a pain at work and
verify whether it requires any argument
we've got to give you the end such as pas de
Murcia here and selling apartment so you are
you have to have a partner at work at run as
you have been saying over and over and that
would be Calico but it doesn't say install a
partner at work out on
that's the key difference it says choose
upon that work out on and in the pot that
were going to be added after the fact and
that's not completely Apparent from reading
this so your explanation is a Bee Gees
explanations have definitely been been good
here
so
do do do
I see
all right so we're going to do I'm in a
hurry by Calico
I really kind of bummed that I can't tell
what sea and I are used to work
hey and seems like a real Tivoli simple
thing to figure out I'm kind of bummed about
that because you know it shouldn't it should
not be taking
this long to figure this stuff out you know
I'm saying
so let's try
ssds are in front of me I have you tried
respond and Polly bar do not know what they
are
do you not know what they are
veterans business unit manager now I would
never care about that I don't use when do
managers Eisenhower comes on the system
I'm not a fan of I went to management people
are so that's fun days in the agent ran and
yeah just like a game all right I'm not mad
at you in a little bit if not afraid sick
I'm a little bit sick of hitting this pain
point with communities
the main point is this decides to abstract
some a critical component of the
infrastructure the network between the pods
the entire concept of storage the you know
the other one the c n i c s i o n in cursive
is it with him a sense right now you just
have to have it
we're not going to give you any way to know
which one you have
and they did the same thing there's a new
thing called the CSI emergency metrics
there's some interesting so if they're going
to break this is this is this is this isn't
my complain all right so I can play with
kubernetes as a project is that it has
allowed these abstractions to happen without
including as a part of the standardization
of the interfaces you know she aside
whatever some form of metadata registration
so that people can easily get information
about the cluster
so you're expected to go outside of the
cluster and to know what to look for but
that is a wild goose chase if you're coming
into an environment where you don't know
what your cluster is the planet and people
say well if you don't know where your custom
player you got bigger problems but as the
amount of cloud deployments on-prem
continues to increase the number of contract
contract professionals and people that need
to be able to quickly assess
what's up right get a lay of the land once
your seeing-eye who is there a storage glass
bubble but how are you doing everything here
being able to quickly audit and discover
they like the discovery step from 70 right
we need to be able to quickly assess what
we're dealing with here right so I mean if
your doctor and so did you bring a patient
in you come over you get their body weight
or sex or gender you are there their history
to Medical drug you know it's a number of
things that you would look at before you
started dealing with the issues and my the
pain pointment kubernetes is there is no
standard way to do that and we missed an
opportunity to cover days rule in my opinion
because they didn't add it to the
abstraction when they decided to get rid of
Darker by the way I mean I think doctors can
actually check with you know it really
doesn't matter though right because the pain
is back in your plan a different Leah can
have a different stator engine but I
understand it but
there should have been some way to query
Potter game or something like that and say
what is your container run time over here
and and he was asked on your business I just
it's just a container in time that's all you
need to know as soon as they were what was
storage is it was providing this PVC I mean
what what is the type of sort of an end
after taking the case is a bit more
visibility into and you can know the type of
storage class with us and Festus of is
actually a storage class you can query with
Calico you don't have it seems to be the way
to do this
actually I wonder what it's probably in the
annotations
they're I think they may have actually added
when I did I know they did it with no future
discovery
I bet you I bet you there's annotation we
don't know of
I bet you there is it seems like it would be
it would be too much right
so
now I have a very simple problem I am the
contractor on supporting a kubernetes
cluster and I cannot answer the question
what is RC and I on my own
I have to go back and look up tribal
knowledge or
college or look for any number of common
things that might be associated with a given
C and I to do some detective work to see
what the fuck were using and that that is
not okay it's not okay it should be the
first thing I see I should be able to do a
command and pull it up and you can't so
unless I'm missing something as possible so
he is a little bit little bit annoying I
won't lie
yeah I can see
so yeah
I I I I I I feel like I need to end for the
day because I can't figure out
I'm not I'm not cursing on Karina I'm just
trying to I'm trying to identify the pain
points I don't want him to get the wrong
idea I still think of her days as a valuable
product and blah blah blah I think we should
try to use it I just feel like there's a
number of like no brainer obvious things
that they forgot and I feel maybe they were
too obvious you know wanted to know how
close is your limited you know storage class
provider volumes are which is abstracted
away and unable to check it now they're
adding it right as an emergency measure the
kind of thing they had it back in because
they need to be able to Tessa hey. Everybody
has unlimited cloud storage with no limit
inside and then the other point is right now
I can't tell what my seeing-eye is going to
go ahead and install Calico 4 the point of
this exercise but it kind of annoys me
that's all
so I just want to know is you probably
should you can look at it to see United City
which we did owe I do have access to the
notes
yeah that's something you can run a damaged
job form
right I can probably do an estimate on that
and go look at it
I don't know because I don't have access
outside and then I've accessed outside their
shirt environment
I'm looking to know real quick I'll be right
back
can I see Calico in there yeah we got Calico
for sure
I'm trying to think here
yeah so I think I have enough to go on
Nellis to Calico and go ahead and put that
in there we just need to add it to the
insulation in the provision
and I don't I guess everything
listen to We have to do this you don't have
a secondary provisioning things you have to
do nothing in it
right actually okay so that's not something
that's not something we can we can automate
I mean we can but it's you know the
difference set
so we have to say deploy
I see you and I and it but I work tonight
yet
Hangout Festival next install I know
all right so preferably Calico so that we
can
so now we can return your PA's rifle be
Calico
this is a step that comes after everything
else you know what I mean
needed to focus my 4K kit Calico
if I guess what iris or fire on window side
yeah lyrics it's also mandated by most
governments and work like that for banks and
stuff so it's not something you can easily
dismiss to fortunately so it's actually one
of the reasons I chose to send him I mean a
red hat Enterprise Linux compatible host OS
because I want to be enterprising
before joining else do you do it before
joining the notes
and since I didn't create the fish that gay
and I'm going to say
join the worker nodes
send message login for controlling node I am
happy
as a great song I was a happy little song
little song
alright so
I Thinking Out Loud so
Chris has a serious run if you don't deploy
turn working right so I got to do calico
and I just one else I need to do here
already got the vacuum Indian this stuff is
already working so high how are you
2001 Forester last year what he like the
Forester
this cute little car it's a Forester or the
other one
yeah you can just go as I said something she
does she's going she's getting ready to go I
are all she's doing the road Mike seen that
right here she's in the same Mike's she's
literally preparing to go to testing no rip
which lets you stream from anywhere in the
world so I'm kind of watching this setup
that's going on there because I kind of I
know I'm kind of distracted kind of working
yeah it's coming
your application
I was buying a car okay so I put it okay so
I'm sorry I'm not okay yeah
and I'm hoping there's too many helpers yeah
dementia communities it right since it
started making no I don't think so at all
no the best thing the best thing that many
kids can get
sing that minikube can get you and I visit
after a year okay so I've been employed a
full year
yeah that was Mark something right March 5th
as the name Merced Merced sounds right yeah
all right my first full year and I'm just
talking to them about this so so and we
don't have we still don't have a handle on
how to terminate his works is so fucking
complicated it's like so huge so
yeah there's just too much to learn okay so
you kind of Mini Cooper great for you to get
an understanding of like what resources are
white people use communities from an
application perspective and maybe even
practicing so I have services and stuff but
if you want to do on plant on for a doctor's
appointments or you want to administer
kubernetes in any capacity even in Cloud
you can't fully understand it without doing
your own deployment a my opinion my opinion
I think it's okay to rest but still quite
different yeah and that's why I'm doing what
I'm doing right now I'm doing everything
that I literally the exact steps that I
would do if I had a machine at a company and
they said set me up a non-friend kubernetes
cluster is exactly the same exactly the same
so there's there's any I'm using vagrant to
2 to bring the machines up but beyond that
it's exactly the same thing and the reason
this is super important because my interests
lie in creating automation software that
digs underneath the hood deeply it to see
what's going on and it starts to report on
and things like that so if you want to write
software for kubernetes or do you want to
write applications to do coronavirus in
ministration many Cuban kind will never be
good enough because they're not the actual
thing
so it is very very overwhelming and I I
don't I don't mind saying so it's not for
everybody but it is
you know it's good enough it's good enough
to like start on some things
so yeah I mean I'm not I'm not yelling here
anybody I just I'm just kind of
kind of
a boy it's a second look here
a cubit someplace
but not in here right
I like this I think it's a good way to make
sure you know how it works yeah
you know the environments from scratch
rather than using visual studio yeah
absolutely it's very much the same and
that's why I'm kind of I'm going to make
sure it's growing on me again now that it
works
Cube Outlet
I said spell I think right I think that's
how it's spelled
a comment oh sorry yes could catch thank you
muchly
that I did none of this matters I don't even
know how to
okay we're doing the party tonight so I have
to install the Calico thing which can't be
done from the provisioning this is a step
you have to do from Hand by hand means I got
to get on the 60 my God
that cornbread dinner is coming people
and I'm almost ready to do the rest of the
stuff
alright so let's try this omnomnom oh my
gosh I just got to this smell holy cow she
baked it in a cast iron pan
and I just got a full way of the scent of
finally made it to my nose so hungry
I hear we going to the next thing
SSH into control actually is going to I
can't do it I got to know what to do or if I
hear you have to change it to the host name
something your fine I'd so when it's all
calico so
how do I install Calico interested in this
is
that
I cannot answer a bunch of multiple-choice
questions about kubernetes that I couldn't
answer before one of them is
does communities have just give me the M
communities come with a c and I by default
the answer is absolutely not
is that it is it from the docks
it absolutely does not
and that's a problem right that's a big
problem to me
because
yes and I doubt it but now you can answer
the question right when I want to know is
does it come with the stores close by the
4th I have a feeling the answer is also no
I think the only stores close because my
default is host local storage which is like
super bad and you should never use it
astroneer Docs
because why do we need to keep it do we
wait. You keeping it again I think I do
I think I need you to admit where am I at
I am available today right so see this cuz
Wednesday I sat there
you can talk to the server cuz there is no
server there is no server
was in the same container any problem we had
before
so it keeps the electorate yes yes yes I do
you do that
I I I want to say we didn't damn it the
right thank you I need to do that a million
other times I need to keep making them the
steak so that I remember it is right now I
haven't I'm not remembering it
but in yes great idea put in your passenger
seat he says start a picture of they say
imagine being put something in the trash RC
you're absolutely right you're totally right
I feel like we have a CNA now he get fonts
can you see if she'll get notes hey look it
says ready now
put in Jersey Shore RC yeah you better copy
that shit just kidding yeah I already know I
looked I know it's going to be here now
because I looked at my production system
that work cuz say Calico in here and I know
what's up
in fact I got to make a note about this
less I could figure out
is to look in C & I
HD and he's the process
the nation
22222222 system
for example afterafter having installed
Calico
I have I have the following
pug shelters right now M Avery red how are
you thank you for following there
and I'm quick side missed you earlier thank
you
Safari you guys. Leslie
Leslie doing no trip here if you're not
falling Leslie to go follow right now I'm
sorry I'm being very distracted by her if
she's screaming she's she's screaming she's
using that I owe you guys know what I've
been in IRL streamer I've been skateboarding
and biking get everything right and Leslie
and I and a bunch of other eye or else
Reimers have been trying to figure out the
best possible remote set and she's got she's
got the road Mike on right now and we
actually did some of that equation on
whether this is the best go into the road go
to about which one to use
and so there's another number of other guy
just got her whole family there hanging out
all the bunch of teenagers so she's I'm
trying trying to figure out what and Cameron
should have going with but she's getting
ready to do a bunch of IRL streaming so
that's something if you want that follows
like I really recommend that she's
reverberate IRL streamer
and I'm going to I'm going to put just going
to put that in the trash can add her to my
recommended because she's getting ready to
do a digital nomadic stuff and like now that
I have my own car as of today you're going
to see me like going on camping trips as I
could do before it was I didn't have a car I
didn't have a car because my wife has the
car all the times I was stuck here and now
that I have a car coming
I'm going to be doing a lot more IRL
streaming so that's why I'm in such kind of
tangent but super excited about that I got
wheels yeah I mean you guys know before I
was going to the pubs and I was doing it
live music streams and I was I was going for
a walk to get the board to go on walks in
the same place now if it was have a car I
can go anywhere anytime any day and I'm
going to go do all kinds of IRL stream
including text you before the road I'm going
to start taking I'm going to be starting to
take trips with the campsites in like
remotely programming and remotely streaming
and doing in our communities on the road and
maybe maybe even doing some side Consulting
you know interviewing people that I've
always wanted to do go find them and energy
than live so I have all the equipment for
that if I kept the GoPro after I thought I
was going to nights at one thing I get back
to the Copa so so I have all that now and
now we have a car that goes with it
so so you're going to see me following a lot
more of the Cyril stuff so that's cool
yeah
if anybody's going to put that out there
alright I'll send you to start doing yoga
again I used to actually live stream yoga
I'm still going to do that I have a lot of
things I want to start bringing back and
meet I'm really easy install so
I feel like we got we got our answer quite
we are a question answer it cuz it has the
advanced tutorial work day for crowd really
that's awesome
that's it that's awesome I'm I'm glad you
guys are like reaching out and doing that
kind of thing you know a new event also
can't go without tool can I guess a lot of
people have recommended k-9s and people that
I highly respect I am going to avoid K9s for
now the reason I've been waiting since I
wanted to get good with the actual commands
and then I would add it all and that into my
United Progressive learning kind of idea you
know I want it I want it I really want to
suffer I don't even do aliases it's like get
to write I barely have any leases for you
because I don't I really want to solidify
those commands into my memory with lots and
lots of activity calling regular usage and
then and then and then maybe I'll make it
easier for myself you know
it's kind of goes everything like I build my
own computers all the time and did it
multiple times and it is so many times I can
probably do it again if I need to just been
a long time but I can do it and I don't need
to do it anymore so I buy a computer same
thing goes for skills I think it's important
that you don't put too much magic as my
phone is so fuzzy finders in the extra stuff
and you know all these extra magical tools
because they're not the things that come
with basic Unix and you can have a problem
because later on you're going to not
remember any of those things when you get on
the system we're going to be asked to use
that weather be for I90 North Acacia and or
or just you know as an operator it depends
on the career obviously if you can be is
just a developer those sort of things don't
matter as much but for me and not doing it
that's that's what is Rachel I watch other
streamers use it I think all the stream of
theft ring whenever I saw him using it quite
a bit I think it's worth looking into I just
I want to be really cognizant of that
beginner thing
yeah and keep sitio can do so much you can
have your own plugins to it which I found
out I have a problem because I typed Kate
all the time though right because I've
already done that so even so yeah it's going
to be good good times
so what are we doing next
all right let's do
but I feel like we got everything that we
just need to join some of the network right
I mean we got a pot so you can do that
before I know we can
right so we've got we had our our our
calcoastcu night which was not hard
I do want to write that down though
I didn't write it down I don't know where to
put it I don't know where to put it
stuff I would have anything here Ted stuff
to do
after key rhenium and it has been run
I understand where the rest of the note so I
can put them here
I think we need to add hostnames yes it does
that but I don't know how to do it is
there's a there's a setting for it and I
have no way to get that to work yet
yeah let's do the host names so we need to
do
that's not as Leslie god dammit
communities doesn't eat it I think we
probably want to add it anyway though right
artist
what is calico I think
into the new people coming to kubernetes
this is one of the things that's the most
daunting and frustrating there's so much
shit you have to know that has nothing to do
with these nights it gives you your present
work so it doesn't come with that by default
no cavities is not batteries included is the
opposite
is calico from Tanzania
1010 seems like the network diagram right
that this visualization thing from from
VMware
yeah housing a stroller and then it says
Calico Felix bird
ideals of your routes that's cool
raise objects Linux host Aku kecewa a Saiga
12 pockets for
do these are the controllers that come with
it so it actually does it actually adding a
bunch of CRTs for for that controllers
that's cool and then it has
give you ice over a calculator store
yep easy-peasyeasy Bebe
I've heard of that busy P I have
I heard vzp before but I was not aware of it
that's super cool
all right so I want to make sure we have his
stuff in there
that is not a component that actually I
think I might have been emailed about a
diagram I think it might have been
all right
let me know the next time I don't know if we
need to get home or not let's join a worker
we haven't done that that's like what we've
been the shooting to try to do all this time
so that's three fresh had to do that so I
need to do
q c t l you think we need to change horse
names
we for sure we need to change the hose
clamps alright I'm at issues I don't forget
change the hosts names of each machine
god dammit
hang up alright so
no name is inferred from it it actually
isn't it God damn it I forgot about that
I didn't realize no name was inferred from
it to fuck you know what let's do that and
then reprovision I know let me get one thing
to join I might get one thing and then we'll
come back and do that because that's
definitely a thing we need to do so
yeah
horse names
I don't know how to set the post immigrant
maybe I found it but I wasn't able to do so
just for u s v n. Hostname or something
if you want to research that while I'm doing
this other stuff I have been go if you don't
want to that's why I want to get it to join
yeah I know it's got that's the hard part
it's not that's why I had a problem it's
like you have to do
you have to add it to the host file I think
and then you also have to set the name in
Vigor as well
I remember so
be in the house and yeah that's what I said
but it didn't pick up and I was like you
know
eye surgeon yeah that's exactly the page I
was reading
I literally out of this the problem I have
is that it's a no. Where is it
Jose Figueroa update as you know something
else in the kickers of all the host name of
the machine should have default see if Neal
Bennett will not measure those names it's
interesting though say what you said to will
be set on boot
I don't know I asked it didn't work that's
right again though
no. VM. Hostname oh I think I know it was
no. VM. Hostname
I think I think the problem was I was trying
to do the temple literal or the
I sent a letter what's a little name
and I don't think it works for you. Love
with you
it is essential to the note for sure yeah
but the
I know we're at it's not Stouffer I just get
this money to joinis willing to join yeah
I'm going to try my join
we got to go to work successfully already so
I know I know that that is is workable but I
want to do overtime Ray Grant is cessation
to node one
and I want to seem to join Network so so you
do
Cube ATM I didn't cut and paste that I can
buy from the other one
Sydney White iridium join was it let's join
command
god dammit
Indiana completion
cute Indian
soaking
West Lafayette Ewing
I don't know which one it is
another word for yeah but it's not good
enough though
are changing it supposed to
where the hell is his wing command I do not
know
which one is it to make config
token token token token I think it's soaking
I think it is
new
search I'm trying to find the joint command
you can stay
it is I don't remember I can't I'm kind of
hell bent on finding it here though I
thought it was in it
no I don't want space there's other places
by the way I can go read about them all
you can't if you didn't save it
can you can you can for the drink Amanda I
did it
all right right right give me DM token so we
have to generate a new token and then we
have to do the joint command thing
no it's not it's not there
comedian token generate on the phone right
now
I think I am that's why I can't talk cuz I
have a whole thing
I think I think this is the one but it's not
telling me that I can do it
is this one of the secret commands no
is it create hey there
to the MC.
Damn wait a minute I file again
I shouldn't hear that I already did
qntm token create create
show
is it Prince ranking man
are Astrid s h
how can I create
I told y'all to find it next time token
create yes I'm done
print joint command there it is
there we go that's what we want
right now at a copy this shit to my other
one
I need the phone on the screen cuz and I
can't ask Lovett Missouri to very annoying
realities
mom no City
no sitter for you
all this looks for a very encouraging now
you see my watch right
girl stuff teasing a furnace fan
yeah
Pegasus well Calico then getting sold on
here
I think
I think I think it's because it's too far on
6443 getting blocked but you anything
yeah
I can get to it it's just that to that thing
right Ant-Man
I got to get his Coronavirus I ain't even
calling here
no route to host yeah tell him that there's
like a million things
look at that cat to it in all the hackers
skills
this work is it routes to it when you paying
but it doesn't otherwise oh wait that's the
wrong one
the right now is right I can make it though
that's weird I sent paperwork said but
nothing from these people so down
wait wait in line app I know time travel
systemctl firewall d right
Kevin Rafael Diaz
I haven't worked for her roles in the very
long time that everything's changed
disabled I I didn't see if I will be in
see
I think it might be a teaspoon if you
problem let me know if your tables problem I
could have Calico
Calico should be deployed after the fact
right
oh right right right right right thank you
for that
Sims CC list
all right is that okay nice I don't know why
they said systemctl
stop fire all day
and we'll have to poke a hole in it for sure
they didn't say a lot about that in the
notes and then notes for sending it up just
to make sure you got all your holes
available if you know
cell
oh shit
at the token Discovery Tok shit
Discovery Tok it's the discovery Tok
made of hashes Discovery joke
made of hash
the farewell
I'm guessing down connection I guess it
could be outbound or inbound when you do it
by the way it needs to be off on both right
well that was it
sounds like that ready already exist in the
Gloucester
I Know It with name Logan name already exist
in the closer you must delete the existing
Elder change the name ye that I wanted to be
here with that I wanted to see what that are
look like learning through failure
obviously write learning through as a
failure
I feel I feel like we are very close to
success here
it's going to take us a while but we're
going to get there we're going to get there
people
so Jenna Justine Simmons. S
you can if it's within 45 seconds or
whatever 45 minutes or whatever the ttla
come it goes bad after a while
after while does it goes bad he's a host
name and then
do you mean right it's right you mean on
this one Hi Sam she wanted to see me
she still thinks that I'm going to do that
eventually
why you see things about me
she hasn't done anything yet today
this dog come here
she's like to get picked up what
I go get your can't do the thing honey oh my
God all right we have one last note to join
and then I can do
going and then I can do family stuff did you
hear me wait
just like weights just as she knows that
when she hates it though we're so close
for a long time I can say yeah host name
blah
well that wasn't good
I mean it doesn't matter now host name
I am I was named blah yeah they're going to
join
I was involved can I be reduced
the envelope servicing misbehaving
zilliqa coin
I'm not watching the Moga
them it's a labrador a little bit 11 or a
little bit of rat terrier boxer at Susan as
soon as Susan her dog
what what are we doing here why didn't this
work
oh yeah shut lunski sitter
I should low-key sit there a Swedish Bulldog
sitter
I need to know if I could have a way to
keabadian reset
depends on what system of arms
cute ATM reset the journalist is that fine
yes I want to reset unmounting humid
do I have to do that on why not
I know I don't know okay so
visit okay lesson learn qadeem is on
everything every time I think I might be
ready I'm going to control playing in that
was a false perception of mine. You might be
the over here
on the joining oh yeah I want to feel you
can't even talk to her anymore we don't have
to do an indent probably probably do
like I said I can be ready to do so you must
remove but we want to keep seeing eye
I'd rather give it a try. It
because his wife's yes it is my cluster is
dead so see this listing of cube
and it keabadian Annette's
that is that is
I really want to think about this for a
second that is the equivalent of the worst
possible our msrf you could ever do on your
cluster
and I'm really glad I did it in a test
environment here can you imagine doing a
cube ATM reset in production
I mean like I don't even like a fireable
offense so I'm really glad I just did it to
myself here and it's nice safe environment
the question is do I want to do and I join
here not if you have an h a control plane
why would that only do it but when the
command the command only affect the one
plane
the one plane number a Scottish Setter so it
is a Setter okay
very nice
try the recess in his only iFixit
underground a game
I thought I send it this one too yeah yeah
yeah yeah we're going to do
Q Indian reset yes
I said Justin Gavin didn't give me the
warning
received two arguments
token discovery
I think there's no spacer there we go yep
whatever he's asking a lot like a lot a lot
a lot service behaving
if I saw you can look at the calendar for
vision start over
yeah I'm going to reprovision start over
because we had too many pieces missing
Ganymede
send like a
you think they got saved in the in the data
you think I got to say the name to didn't it
did
reset yes delete it all
reset yes delete it all and which one is
which
control hostname no 21
cute ATM and it
generating to keep hairs Etc
Hannibal MO change I want to change it and
out now to be stored inside
hey it looks happier it looks happy or and
looks happier
woohoo
yay now I didn't
I didn't I didn't I didn't it said it left
to see a nice up there but I bet I still
have to install it
noted mean Citizens Medical Center
waiting for the Kubota from Taylor Swift
rapping
not ready to see what's up let's see what's
up do you think we have to run it anyway
I promise not to do the deployment right
because there was only the one and the
reason is because it has the one it it has
the one for this computer by me for this
machine but not for the other machine right
and it didn't push it down because it had
directly to the cash or something so
we got to get that ACP come out again if I
can find it
Erie said Custer twice right I know but but
did you notice how it said that it didn't
remove the stuff from seeing light at 69
yeah I look which is I want to take note of
this is a big deal it left the stuff here
see that's why this one says ready look
that's my
that's my battery right that this one says
ready but this one doesn't
yeah I know there's more stuff I figure
that's that's why we're getting it so we're
going to go find the issue to pick him out
again
Galvez yes, yes of course of course the
other Calico files aren't there we need them
to talk to you right there we go yeah and
that's going to fix it I bet you that fixes
it
I might have to reset the the Pod do
I know there goes yeah we had a healthy
nodes we have healthy notes
yep
I think that's probably good for me I'm
going to be a nice my straightener but he's
playing a game early this is great this is
like really really great
I put I put the information the provision of
adding Calico pods
we need to fix the hostname for you to get
the hosts names get buds
yeah I like that. Give your IP numbers
get us ghetto pods that will show us all the
Calico pods
and what servers are running on right this
will also give us
the hours are calico controllers running on
keep system keep himself which is this which
is reserved in space and
we can everything so there should be other
controller that we have this one is running
on known one
is it on Econo control no one
so these are all the positive running and if
he's a demon stats
I think you proxy all shows Jameson right
imma get
Steven said that she
yeah let me go get out so there's a Damon
says I said keep Roxy's in front of the damn
said when you're being who they have the
documentation about components the required
for a TenPoint it's very confusing because
it says there has to be a proxy do you like
what the fuck is give Roxy Roxy is built
into Cubit is supported as a as a demon side
now even though it's an essential component
if so we have to know that on the test and
Calico node is apparently the cni provider
that's been deployed as a demon said as well
so that's really good to know Damon sets run
one per node every machine get to Damon said
I didn't know if you discover it's also
damned it said there's lots of them out
there
all right so what else we got we got
oh yeah Chris Christie telepods I got to hit
you with that
oh my God so fucking cool
I wonder if we want to run container to
instead
I got it I got a request I got to go a
container Dean I got a suggested we like
migrated over to it
that's like a big fucking deal is in the
fall 10 points
make sure you're running as I'm not cuz I'm
not using it
you can set socket I think
what time you connect using the fall 10
points oh so this is like it's having to
guess
that's something you might want to put in
our default the Etsy Crissy Field account
file in our provisioning I kind of want to
do that so that it doesn't do that every
time I mean so
God damn this is cool thank u l g l d b l v
d l b g I appreciate this so much
I appreciate this so much you have no idea
so
no on Etsy Microsoft stock at secrecy t l
are there isn't one seems like I have to go
and go find it
it's a first time I have never heard of
Chrissy till in my life I have never heard
of it
Maleficent standards
you had to take. Culture in your company's
so we got to talk about something once a
week now know we don't there's still a bunch
of hoarding that goes on in this company
is that really mean or malicious there's
just like need to know kind of basis it's
kind of sad actually
I don't think it's I don't think it's
institutionalize it's just the way it is you
think I'm never going to add a bunch of
discoveries from this I have written
proposals and stuff that had for the
information reports I've discovered cell
I'm going to learn all about Kris ETL c r i
c k l
it's a whole technocrat thing yeah it's a
different and honestly it's not like it's
like anybody on my team is like saying you
can't learn this lesson or I won't answer
cuz it's not that it's his sister's not an
active exchange of information because it's
mostly because it just takes time you know
and unless you're being trained for being
trained or kind of is
that knowledge do ya you'll find that by the
way
image endpoint current time in Pointe
Imaging appointment I got to learn all about
Chrissy till now
the commands can I use a point if you have a
greasy tools to create pots that make sense
of containers on the run time for my event
Lidl eat them
that's why it is useful for debugging it
looks like it's so much better than darker
for debugging
God damn why are we not using this I really
want to push for this
I really want to push me this
I think it will save time 2 I don't know
where it came from I have had to live
through it though I'm telling you
it's a native committee siggno it's a
container D thing
and it's like way it's way better than
darker or I just found out about it today it
is the first day of that out
and I like oh my God I think I got upset
about it cuz it's so cool
it's Community sing
it is that's all it is huh nice
muscle relaxer the moment really
what kind of a tradition rather its Mission
how are you how are you to point are you
playing it in the cloud so you don't have to
do all the song from kind of dumb stuff or
Canadian
assume so hello there holy cow
yeah did you buy enough food for you live in
the house for a the house for a month
come rescue precious at least once
you know it hurts the crazy thing is I
haven't left the house in a month so
no I probably should change but
buyer's remorse
watch out I told you listen to the spirit
to the forest get it okay
you should be happy for another reason you
can beat the shit out of it and never have
to deal with me again
did you get a nice car no I'm going to look
at it and go
ruining the car every time
you could
I said my car is your I said that we're
going to be that we're going to get like
that I'm afraid a little bit
you can see where the fuck you want
no sir I realized my car
has better climate control I was just
telling them cuz I can go I can go camping
now I can't turn it on I go camping and I T
support doesn't if I were to try to sit in
the back of it and like plug
I don't want all the tech in mind but if I'm
going to be
go back to what I have my original plan was
before I got it is a car I can beat up that
has really good at this one like I roll the
reviews is supposed to be amazing in the
snow and everything but it's made for like
off-road stuff so it's four wheel drive so
50% of the power goes to the front 50% goes
in the back and they say it it like gives it
slightly less like mileage per gallon all
that you have Oye which is the most
important thing based on where we're going
so well I'm I'm I'm in the remote Bluetooth
for my phone and everything like that in the
good one and one that's going to be a thing
because then I can just turn it on and I can
I think I'm going to be asking me my office
basically the portable office yeah and so
that'll be a thing all right we're just
excited cuz she bought a car
online by the way it's being delivered and
we just bought a car
was because we had to
and a selfie was like his head open your
mouth close your mouth and then it processed
the same really
did it
I probably should ask you all find did you
did give me the finance and everything just
went through no problem right
oh that's right I forgot we're paying cash
we're paying cash for a car
not a caravan fuck no I will never own
another Caravan how dare you
always talking about the Subaru car about it
All That season 1 I don't know is that the
service we talked about
which I'm grateful for the community
I did buy the series my wife bought the
Forester for cash from California for like 4
grand We Got the Beat her so that she can
beat it up
I was about to write lesson we're looking to
always pay cash because of what the fuck I
might as well just get it on the way
casually bring about paying cash on stream
I guess so I guess I am yeah yeah I'm
bragging I paid cash God damn it I didn't
curly
I am safe for a person I love it I have one
tenth of the way
Porsche lease a car for cash on stream and
like yeah damn it I guess am I bugging you
fucking agent for like five grand or
something
Porsche did 911
I don't know maybe a certified psychiatrist
Among Us
yeah they're insane they were and say hey
Ivan welcome
I got a pair of ski that I live just like a
really great Russian name Slavic name I
should say to me I seen the Russian and
Romanian or something then like fucking ring
and yes we bought the Subaru but we bought
the Forester and not the Outback by the what
I can have I can't believe I can say that
now I have a car finally
and neither of us will have our cars for
many weeks no we won't know we are stuck in
the house case anybody wants to save us
we're stuck in this about to walk to the
store cuz I have no vehicle
as insane as it said you think you think we
were college kids
like when I bought a vacuum and walked it
home from Sears
oh boy is going to give me a ride
you too I can get the pajamas out
oh my God yes yeah they like the girl the
girls night out in the waist on a sleepover
a society might what is the thing you're
gone know your whole girls thing that you're
doing a salon it's an artist Salon it's a
salon
yeah that's right you should have fun with
that
but I'm going to Camping like every week I
only got to be camping out just say no I
getting a fucking car I'm just drive drive
drive drive drive drive drive drive around
to whoever has internet I'm just going to
sleep out in camp out I cannot wait I cannot
wait I'm so tired of being stuck in this
apartment
is it going to fisherman he said K he's
actually fine now
yeah he said if I didn't have any had a
fever one day and it went away but he added
that he had the immunizations both of them
so yeah
and so yeah he he has been
quarantine for last you know in his room for
a while and he supposedly not contagious
anymore if so none of us have had any of the
symptoms my wife's got to get every test but
we're fine so nobody said anything more of
the story I mean the vaccination is
definitely worth it just to minimize the
symptoms when you do get it even if you do
get it I mean yeah we're going to fight
about this but immunizations are not to
prevent you from getting a necessarily it
does it's like if you do get it at like
reduces the impact
imma versus regular today I'm really torn
because I like them both but I think they're
the reason I do
there's a reason I do too I'm over the
element as charm chunky chunky does it
chunky recommended very highly and they use
a lot babies in one
I'm going to tell my sister sister
absolutely
so so so so
what have you got going on here we have
we're learning about Kris ETL
crittall whatever it's so cool I can listen
to all the individual pods
I am so glad I booted Docker off of my
cluster and I have nothing but container you
now
you know why I'm sick of people telling us
oh just go log into root on assisting with
darker and use it because you don't have it
on your desktop
that's something somebody has actually done
and said and recommended that was like that
is an anti pattern
do not do that
that I had to buy the last thing I need to
be able to get
Persimmons new ideas to warrant and
compatibility with a new name to be a almost
almost enough to make somebody into a PhD
pen which I am
that's anybody mistaken
so did you see tell him I was saying that
apple is if you see that did you see that
apple
I was just it was his fat he was doing some
research and he couldn't he found a report
that showed that Apple Darwin is the largest
official
Unix distribution in the world
I already sent it that way I was like a
little shocked I was like that's true though
it's the largest it exist I mean people
think of the largest unit distribution I'm
thinking like Beastie or previously of me to
see me something and
the actual by number the largest the largest
percentage
if it wasn't it was Apple and Beats a ax
a b a i a lane you bring up a time one time
was the one who brought it up I was like
you're not going to want to hear this sound
like what
Louisville news apple bad
and if I can cash a while back to certify
this evening cuz it's not really a Knicks
do they tax the paper that what all do you
have any reference to that oh my God this by
our way into the unique school club that is
like scandalous that is some Scandal right
there oh my God
has some great Scandal I like that a lot
never get from Scenic State Park
pythons skip that day because it was
compiled on a 00
that does not surprise me I am glad to be
out of the Python ecosystem however
I've been largely instructed to use Python
for our Disk Utility modern which I got to
go work out tomorrow we can do the next
thing which is understanding of NFS on my
nodes
and testing those by filling them
I don't know how mama do that because I need
to set up a class and that's the thing
actually needs to be in this tutorial is
thingamabob wait we need to have that
lime thing
FS is a greasy absolutely is ya I did it the
other day but we need me to make sure if you
can join the worker nodes
create an n f s
Mount volume
create a storage
class for a n f s volume
is mostly an example and yeah I thought it
was yes we do suspect Unix is a trademark
it is actually a TV right like $3,000 a seat
when it was first when it was first made
I mean it was a lot right it was it cost a
lot of money as a big deal
I don't know why I'm yawning so much kind of
played out or something
God I feel like I've accomplished so much
today thanks to our great Community
specifically lvg for today we actually got
all the way in. The only thing left it's
kind of grating on me is having the nodes
set their hosts names and I'm going to go
through and I'm going to reprovision based
on that until I get that done and then I am
going to be done for the day and working
since noon or so on this on this specific
task
and I feel really good about it though
this is why I feel like I feel like I could
go in and create a rock ronettis cluster
from scratch now
and obviously there's a bunch of other shit
you have to add into it but you know it
doesn't have an Ingress to find
my CK is already scheduled
oh no I'm not see schedule a message okay I
have a lot to do before that yet this kiss
it's just said schedule
is rubbing this is so a lot of the stuff
that I'm doing right now which is related to
work obviously is going to be powering up
the hours of boosting content that we do a
beginning of February so we're going to
finish up see one way or another we probably
won't finish the book by February 5th
unfortunately I can't afford to wait on this
other covid-19 stuff because I got the I got
to I got to finish the search before June
something
I am going to ya before I think I have until
July 5th to take all the certification exams
I sent it for all three
so I feel pretty confident to be able to do
the sea KD stuff
invited to speak at a stuff is stuff that I
was kind of kind of on the fence about it I
still need to get good with Services we did
a whole thing we can eat now alright so I'm
going to go ahead and and just fix the
is that one last thing so we put in our
provider of a provision of provision
I'm not going to do the KC and I know not
after what you said no I have to do the
security one which is most of our black
stuff I understand
that's what I've been told him I'm in
Destroy all this wonderful work I just did
and I'm going to present another thing I
want to add to this
the provision we're doing here is
well I don't even really need it cuz it's
just bigger and bigger can do the
connections I don't make it to the internet
sensation stuff okay so vagrants
destroy yes yes
I'm going to see if it'll bring up the the
whole stamps I don't think it will six-pack
how are you and Morgan Morgenstern
Morgenstern how are you
we're going to do babe this is somebody
suggested who was it somebody in the
restroom somebody suggested that I should
publish this is a vagrant cloud provider
thing and all the ones we were looking at a
really old so I don't have any details cuz I
never done it and always bigger than 3 days
but I definitely plan on publishing this
vagrant configuration to to the cloud so you
could you should be able to do vagrant up
and then point to mine if you want
customer that uses mediums instead of Mini
Cooper number of of you know advantages but
also has a lot of negatives and so just kind
and so having your own actual cluster
nothing beats that as far as I'm concerned I
do want to do a middle of being some of the
things but I don't know if I even need that
alright so here we go if this doesn't work
it will be because I added host names
and I really want it to waiting for the rain
to get an IP address
but this is what makes us doing right now is
it's it's firing up three
nodes three machines that then turns into
grenade he's nodes
Apple we're advertising OS X is UNIX ahead
of being certified they got in trouble wow
cycad 200 million wow
OS X 10.5 is the first eunuch certified
version wow
that is some great dirt right there that is
some fantastic dirt
until I make sense to me to
I mean meet at the Apple to buy their way in
and you know it just makes sense that they
would do that
I mean to say it again because I was really
hard on vagrant the first day
I'm becoming a bigger and Fanboy even though
it's the old after we got delivered thing
fixed and I realized that vagrant was not to
blame even though delivered provider is kind
of old for vagrant also noticed that there's
very few
vagrant things for chemo there's a lot of
ignorant stuff for virtualbox and almost
none of the you know the clouds that you can
put a bigger and write better than a good
crowd surged almost none of them are human
we so I like that we've got one that uses a
liver provider
because I think it's a better choice for
Trinity's testing and stuff
definitely lighter weight
how much we got it's gone through much of
his finger Friday is provisioning is running
the shell
it's going pretty fast considering what it's
doing as free amazing it's pretty amazing
I mean if complete nothing to do
I said you know now search setting up 3 full
machine
and never again hey Grant now if we did this
right
can I control playing we should be able to
host name
and see it yes if took how can I how can I
didn't work before I hate Ramos
yeah you can really fall I just makes you it
just looks cool it looks so cool
so are we going to do give ATM in it
ackerman's yes
Cube Indian in it
which I cannot do give ATM and it on my own
I mean you know I probably could actually
I can probably add that into the provisioner
after that
the reason I like this where it's at right
now is it leaves me it kind of walks me all
the way up to the point where I'm going to
do my own two configuration as if somebody
had it off the stuff
I didn't start the fire will but I don't
think we needed to stop the firewall
well that's something we can do my hand
right I did not start the firewall no I did
not
alright so vagrants ssage node one
see you as soon as I'm going to try without
that's a good reminder
I really hate doing this but have to do it
we can even remotely want Ramos a point
people will think it's cool they will
no thank its you're really cool if you do
that hey look the firewall still up
systemctl firewall stop firewall d
Perrigo yeah waiting for the keyboard to do
Tales bootstrap
oh I didn't put the paws on okay wait export
I'm going to go see this is what I want to
practice the Thundering right here Etsy
what you didn't take so long run maybe
that's why Packer would be better for like 6
practice or something
kubernetes
Kube config and see communities
admin
thought / Hue and Men completion Bash
oh shit
there we go and then Cube c t l now we can
do
here's ETL
get nodes and they're not ready why are they
not ready I'll tell you why
now that LBZ is help me understand this
they're not ready cuz there's no seeing eye
there's no container
network interface Define so we have to add
Calico Calico
is that the one everybody uses which I put
down here because reasons
what town am I in I'm not in control Clayton
Maps
hey wait it says I'm on known one
I am so happy and this one is that control
all right so we're on the right one they are
pending
I'm going to Cornelius pods I should do that
k
Cuba control cgl
get pods That's Amore
Cortana suspending because they can't talk
cuz there's no networking pods can't talk to
each other cuz they Universe of networking
of PODS is not a thing yet which is what
we're now going to fix
went through the magic of calico
which I have somewhere where the rest of the
day we're going to pull this right off the
internet I don't have to do that
home now watch ending in it
and it's
Annette Annette Annette Annette hot
initialising and that he knew watch but I
don't I'm lazy running
running gordianus is coming up container
created and now it's running
oh yeah that wonderful Calico goodness
and you can call Dennis even courting us is
going to come up
you don't communities is pretty damn amazing
you have to admit
it's pretty damn amazing it really is a mean
you can date on it but
wait so so yeah it's all there it's all
there
nnnn stuff I can agree see telepods
cancel show us all the pods are here so
these are the pods that are running on this
node and this is a command you can run from
the underlying OS of the node
just work the actual process process the
background I've set out to Nolan run back to
my chicks and which is I didn't realize
gordianus was a demon side
I didn't think I realize that or is it a pod
now it is a pod damn it's our pods
damage that have pods in them they just one
plug for a no-sew Calico node is a pot of
compression the fiscal I don't I don't think
I realize accordionist was
I don't think I realized it was a hot one
that's cool to know
so that means everybody got some didn't
answer it's an appointment to replicas by
default really
on every let me see but it's whatever you
know right
I mean I got your name is are you are you
sure
oh wait I need to do that thing
it's a sister service really
ha
it's just when I was born then you're wrong
I guess I did
I think you can sing oasis.com
I'm an idiot
I don't know why that's already I agree.
Of course this is a keyboard
yeah I'm on the key but I forgot
are you sorry it was a cubit and not the
control plane actually wanted to see what I
can do from here so
it's okay so
communities close to 9 p I think you did ask
us her I'm going to go eat with my wife now
it's been really fun
I'm going to drop this way because I don't
really know what I'm going to have plans
later
and so yeah
I'm I'm just going to either do that or
Witcher
I don't know but but I had this is a
tremendous accomplishment so we got our
Network done we had to turn the firewall off
so let's put that in the provision and then
I can leave this alone for the night
we need to turn our provisional off
I kind of feel like we should just turn the
fire off of everything I mean come on we're
just saving us daily likes the right
I tried to do reels for the firewall and I
don't see him here anymore
yeah where's the firewall rules this right
here, sissy jail for Rounds across no that's
that's not fair
SEMO firewall
Sea-Doo scaredy cat scaredy cat
sister city Aldi the studio system Ctrl
stop by Aldi
yep yep
yep that's all that's right, go ahead and
save this so
add a saint. I'm saving right now but I'm
I'm coming if you're already done I'm sorry
disabled now disabled is that a thing
enable disable I did not know how to say I'm
sorry I do not know
and I know that was a thing I kind of said
that I'm going to set up all the file
completion everything to which all
eventually do
chickens today know she made chili out of
chicken
commence and working
set up camphor
silk kissing is wondering if you want the
repo that I just did if you've been watching
all this you want this code until I get it
from vagrant Cloud here you go
the name of the repo you go look at it and
take it apart and do your own thing it does
append on a couple of the Repose so I can
say for the bird and some stuff but if you
want you can and
buckarama thank you for that what is that
like at Grandma
and I am going to be leaving the building
now thank you very much
the fish is back on for a second
I know can just I don't know
officially said they're hoping I'm over here
I don't know what to say so I'm just going
to stop saying anyting
thank you again thank you really I mean I
really sincerely mean that in particular I
just want to put a big huge huge round of
applause for all the help LBG gave today in
fact has been so much great help I really
kind of want to save this far. But I'm not
going to respond for 60 days in the mission
was it out in the meantime though all the
knowledge that we've learned will be able to
distill down to a shorter video that'll land
on YouTube at some point probably when we're
doing the Boost images coming up on February
5th for seek out and then some of the
communities boost
are you going to do for three years while
yeah if it's a cluster was 1.90 my God it's
misspelled, thank you so much for helping us
then
yeah it is our position lvg is the one to
talk to you about the career so this is one
of those moments where I really regret
shutting the stream down so I'm going to let
it run for a bit and I'm just going to leave
the fish on because if you guys want to ask
LBG any information about their career or
what they're doing or how they're doing it
or what jobs are there in this yeah there's
a lot of real real
still here and so please please do that
I need you to find something I don't know if
that's true blood test them an op-ed
codesandbox. Org
nice and developer and operations yes and I
I know the feeling so it can be kind of fun
I'm going to shut up and walk away
walk away and I'll go ahead and just put the
main plus chat on for now
have a great night bye